شغالين أربعة وعشرين ساعة، مذبوح أنا
ومواعيد التسليم للعميل كانت بصراحة ما هي بسيطة
بعدين جاءنا شريك من...
أنا أتذكر من إيطاليا
كبير، ويسوي مراجعة الجودة، ويديرها، ويشوفها مع العميل
فأنا توقعته لما يجي يسأل العميل، كيف الموقع راح يكون؟
كيف سوُّوا الشباب الشغل، وكيف...
تدري أيش سأله؟
وبحكي لك أياها بالإنقليزي، وبحاول أترجمها
قال له: هل نجعلك تبدو جيدًا؟
كان يؤلمني جدًّا أني أشوف جنبي الاستشاري بالبدلة حقته فاتح اللابتوب
وقاعد يشتغل على ملفات في غاية السرية تخص جهة حكومية
أنا قاعد أشوف المعلومات قدامي
قاعد هذا الشخص بكل لا مبالاة، وإهمال
قاعد يشتغل عليها في مكان عام
صح
ففيه تسريبات كثيرة صارت
وممكن أكيد أنت اطلعت على حالات معينة أو ملف معين
فجأة نلاقيه متداول واتساب، شلون؟
عن طريق واحدة من الشركات الاستشارية
فحساسية، وسرية المعلومات
ودي أعرف أكثر، أيش الإجراءات المتبعة داخليًّا لضبطها، وحمايتها؟
كل سنة كل موظفين الشركة عندهم تدريب افتراضي
يعني بيدخل في نظام واختبار، ويعملوا له سيناريو
أنه تارك اللابتوب، وما هو معمول له قفل
لهذه الدرجة، ولازم ينجح في هذا الاختبار
وإذا ما عمله ينفصل من الشركة هذا المتدرب الموجود
الوعي.
فهل معناه أن هذه سكرت كل المنافذ؟ أكيد لا
سولفت مع أحد يعمل في شركة من الشركات الاستشارية
قال لي أنا أعرف أن ساعتي تُسعّر بعشرة أضعاف راتبي
يعني هو مثلًا لنفترض أنه راتبه 30 ألف
تُسعر خدمته بـ 300 ألف لدى الجهة
أيش سبب هذا التضخم الهائل؟
مع أنه هو طبعًا ما يستلم الفارق، وين قاعد يروح الفارق هذا؟
للشركاء، الله يبارك لكم، ولا وين يروح؟
شفنا حالة يمكن ظهرت للإعلام نشرتها «الغارديان»
حالة الفساد في «بي دبليو سي» أستراليا
لما بعض الشركاء اللي عندهم استشارات مع الجهة الضريبية
سرَّبوا معلومات لزملائهم اللي في شركات التدقيق
وكان على أثرها عدَّة تداعيات
اليوم نفس الحالة هنا كنظام
أنه في قطاع مهم قاعد يدخل مع كل الجهات الحكومية
يقدم لهم استشارات
وفيه قطاع جانبه
قاعد يقدم التدقيق لشركات تتعامل مع هذه الجهات
كيف نتجنب حدوث فساد في هذه الحالة؟
احنا زمان كانوا العملاء يتطلَّعوا فينا
يا أخي أنتم مساكين الاستشاريين تشتغلوا إثنا عشر أو ثلاثة عشر
فعلًا هذا معروف عنكم أنه بيئة العمل عندكم قاتلة
يا ابن الحلال، الآن صرنا احنا نقول للشباب في الجهات الحكومية
ريحونا
الله يعينكم، أنتم تشتغلوا، وصرنا احنا نروح، وهم لسَّه شغَّالين
هذا مكسب لا يُقاس
هذا الجيل اللي راح يكمل في الرؤية بعد الـ 2030
هذا سقراط من شركة ثمانية، وأنا عمر الجريسي
أستضيف قادة التحول، والأعمال، والرأي
ضيف حلقتنا اليوم هو الأستاذ رياض النجار
رئيس مجلس إدارة «بي دبليو سي» الشرق الأوسط
والمدير المسؤول في مكتب السعودية
«بي دبليو سي» هي واحدة من الشركات الاستشارية الكبرى
اللي كان لها دور كبير جدًّا في المرحلة الماضية
البعض يرى هذا الدور سلبي
والبعض الآخر يراه دور إيجابي
أقصد فيه دور الشركات الاستشارية
ففي هذه الحلقة تعمَّقنا أكثر في فهم هذه الشركات
أيش تاريخها، وأيش طبيعة عملها؟
أيش كان دورها في مرحلة التحول اللي عشناها في السعودية؟
كثير من التحفظات على عملها
مثل أنهم مجرد يبيعون شرائح عرض
وأنهم شركات تأخذ المعلومات من العميل
ثم ترجع تقدمها بشكل مرتب
أنها شركات تبيع للعميل الكلام اللي يبغى يسمعه
حتى لو كان الكلام خاطئ
تكلمنا عن كثير من المراسلات الخاطئة اللي تحدث داخل هذه الشركات
واستمعنا لتعليق ضيفنا عليها بشكل عام
تكلمنا بطبيعة الحال عن مستقبل هذا القطاع
هل له مستقبل في ظل الذكاء الاصطناعي
اللي صار يستطيع أنه يجمع بيانات، ويجمع مقارنات معيارية
وغيرها من الأدوار اللي تقوم بها هذه الشركات
وختمنا اللقاء كالعادة بأسئلتكم الثمينة
أسئلة مثل، ليش ما في تمكين للسعوديين؟
ليش عدد الشركاء السعوديين قليل في هذه الشركة
وفي القطاع بشكل عام؟
أيش قصة فرعهم اللي في العُلا؟
ليش عندهم فرع في العُلا؟
ومجموعة من أسئلتكم الثمينة
هذا اللقاء برعاية شركة «صفا» للاستثمار
أمّا الآن اترككم مع الحوار
حيّاك الله، أبو بدر، شرّفتنا ونوّرتنا
الله يحيّك، يارب الشرف لنا حبيبي، الله يسلمك
أبو بدر، حدثنا عن تاريخ وبداية هذه الصناعة، صناعة الاستشارات
سؤال ممتاز بصراحة
صناعة الاستشارات بدأت من التدقيق
بدأت المنظمات أوالشركات، المساهمين في هذه الشركات
يطلبوا تدقيق حسابات
وتدقيق على الأداء تبع هذه الشركات
منها طبعًا في التدقيق يطلع مناطق للتحسين لهذه الشركات
مناطق للتحسين
مناطق للتحسين للشركة والثغرات في الـ...
بعدها بدأت الشركات اللي تدقق هذه تحط خدمات، كيف أساعدك؟
أنا عرَّفت وين الخلل
والآن بعطيك خدمة أنه تحسن هذا الموضوع
وتطورت لدرجة أن بعض الأحيان صار قسم الاستشارات في هذه الشركات
أكبر من قسم التدقيق، والأقسام الأخرى
مع أنه هو اللي كان البداية
مع أنه هو كان البداية
وفيه في التاريخ إذا تُنظر عدَّة شركات اللي فُصلت من التدقيق
يعني أخذت الاستشارات، وقالت: يا عمي احنا شركة منفصلة
وعددنا، وأرباحنا أكثر، وانفصلوا
وإذا بتنظر للتاريخ في عدّة شركات سوَّت هذا الموضوع
أشهر الأمثلة؟
أشهر الأمثلة «آرثر آندرسن»
«آندرسن للاستشارات» تاريخيًّا
بَنَت قسم عندها اسمه «الاستشارات الإدارية»
وبعد سنين من هذه السنين
انقسمت الشركة لـ«آندرسن للاستشارات»
وصار عندك «آندرسن» أو «آرثر آندرسن»
و«آندرسن للاستشارات»
ودخلوا في قضايا، ما ودنا ندخل فيها
وقعدوا سنين في المحاكم الدولية
وبعدها انفصلت نهائيًّا قانونيًّا
وصارت شركة معروفة الآن عندنا في السوق
و«آندرسن» للأسف بعدها بكم سنة انتهت
لقضايا في المراجعة في أمريكا
فهي بدأت أن شركات التدقيق الخارجي
اللي تيجي تدقق الأداء المالي للشركات
صارت تقدم خدمات إضافية لهذه الشركات
استشارية بالضبط
أو خدمات استشارية
طيب متى دخل هذا العالم للمنطقة أو للسعودية بشكل خاص؟
دخل قديمًا من التدقيق بنفس الطريقة
في وضعنا احنا «بي دبليو سي» بدأ في عام 1979
وكان التركيز أكثر على التدقيق
وخاصةً مع ظهور تداول، ومع ظهور هذا...
فصار الوعي أنه مراجع الحسابات...
أنا شخصيًّا بدأت خبرتي في الموضوع في التسعينيات
بعد تخرجي من أمريكا
طبعًا أنا من مواليد البلد، ورحت أمريكا ودرست
واشتغلت هناك لفترة عشان أكسب الخبرة
وجئت مبتدئ زي الشباب كلها
فكان أكثر الشركات اللي تحتاج استشارات
كانت الشركات خليني أقول المتطورة شوي مقارنةً بباقي...
يعني منها أرامكو، ومنها البنوك ورفع الخدمات
وكانوا طبعًا يجيبوا المستشارين سواءً من خبراتهم بالتكنولوجيا
سواءً من الخبرات للبنوك اللي في العالم الثاني
كيف احنا نحسن عندنا في الشرق الأوسط
وبدأت تتطور في السعودية بأقسام
بالرعاية الصحيّة أو بالصحة، وبالمناطق الأخرى
لبداية التطور في الحكومة في 2011
2011؟
2011 عندما بدأت الحكومة تنظر إلى برامج تطوير الـ...
برامج الباحثين على العمل كبرنامج «حافز»
وطبعًا بـ 2014 و2015 مع الرؤية ومع التحول الوطني
بدأ الانفعال في هذا السوق، وبدأ يجذب
إذا راح أتطلَّع للماضي في التسعينيات وفي أول الألفين
ما كانت الاستشارة أو شركات الاستشارية
شيء ينظر له الشباب السعودي
كان صعب جدًّا أنَّك تلاقي موظف يبغى يشتغل في هذا المجال
الآن مع الجيل الحديث
ومع انفعال هذه الشركات بجزء من تنفيذ الرؤية، وتنفيذ التحول
أصبح مكان استراتيجي للشركات، ومكان للشباب يطور نفسه
سواءً يكمل في المجال هذا
أو يروح للحكومة يخدم بتنفيذ الرؤية، والتحول الوطني
فراح تلاحظ هذه الشركات كثير من الموظفين اللي كانوا فيها
الآن متواجدين ماسكين مراكز في بعض الجهات
والحمد لله، هذول ساعدوا في التنفيذ الآن
واحنا راح نتطرق إلى دوركم، أو دور الشركات الاستشارية في التحول
في جزء لاحق للحلقة
بس ابتداءً خلينا نعرِّف الناس على هيكل هذه الشركات عادةً
مين يملكها، وأيش أقسام الخدمات المقدمة فيها؟
أنت اليوم رئيس مجلس إدارة الشرق الأوسط
صحيح
والمسؤول عن مكتب السعودية
فممكن نأخذ أمثلة عن المنطقة وعن السعودية بشكل خاص
ممتاز «برايس ووترهاوس كوبرز» في الشرق الأوسط
متواجدة في اثنا عشر دولة
السعودية تعتبر من أكبر الدول اللي في المنطقة
والإمارات، وقطر
من أكبر، وللا أكبر؟
أكبر
أكبر، حسنًا
أكبر بالعوائد، وأكبر بتواجدنا في العملاء والأمور هذه
الآن«بي دبليو سي» في العالم
تحكي على 151 مكتب حول العالم
دخل الشركة في العالم، وهذه المعلومة عامة، ومتوفرة
53 مليار في العالم
دولار؟
دولار
واحنا في الشرق الأوسط
تقريبًا تعاملنا أكبر شيء مع جميع أنحاء العالم
ولكن انتمائنا أكثر شيء أو تعاوننا مع بريطانيا
بريطانيا تمتلك جزء من الشرق الأوسط
الهيكل هي عبارة عن شركاء
يعني عندنا فوق الـ400 شريك في الشرق الأوسط
هذول اللي يملكوا الشركة بقوانين الشركة العالمية
وتابعين لتقييم معين بالنسبة للشركة
ومعايير معينة اللي تعتبرك شريك في هذه الشركة
فالسعودية اليوم كممثل الشركة، وتنفيذ الشركة
أسمع للعملاء الموجودين عندنا، واحتياجاتنا في السوق من موظفين
ومن عملاء، ومن احتياجات للخبرات المتوفرة
أو محتاجينها في السوق
وبهذه نذهب لبقية العالم
إذا كانت متوفرة عندنا الخبرات هذه في الشرق الأوسط
بالاثنا عشر دولة
أفضل لنا نجيب من خبراتنا اللي في...
إذا ما هي متوفرة نذهب لـ...
تقصد المستشارين؟
المستشارين طبعًا
فاحنا نتكلم على شركة واحدة لمنطقة الشرق الأوسط
صحيح
يملكها الـ 400 شريك
وتعمل في إثنا عشر مكتب
في الشرق الأوسط
وهذه المكاتب تتبادل المستشارين، والخبرات بحسب احتياجاتهم
وعندكم منفذ على المستشارين
في بقية الـ 150 مكتب حول العالم
100%
أنا دائمًا بقول: أنه اليوم أنت ما تقدر يكون عندك
كل الخبرات اللي في العالم في الرياض
صح
فقوة الشركة من قوة الشبكة
أن أنا اليوم...
يعني أنت اليوم، قبل خمسة أو ستة أو سبع سنوات
ما كنا محتاجين خبرات في السياحة مثلًا
اليوم محتاجين الخبرات في السياحة
هل أقدر أحوِّل، وأجيب الخبرات هذه
وأوزعها على الشباب يتعلموا من الخبرات هذه
فهي قوة الشركة بقوة الشبكة الموجودة عندها
والمعرفة الموجودة
سواءً في الشرق الأوسط أو في أوربا أو في بقية...
لو بتكلم عن مكتب السعودية كمثال
شلون مقسم كخدمات أو كشركاء؟
اليوم في السعودية احنا عندنا خمس خدمات
عندك «استراتيجي آند»
«استراتيجي آند» تقدم كيف عندك الشركات الاستراتيجية في الشرق الأوسط
كانت في العالم هي «بوز آند كومباني» قبل كم سنة
و«بي دبليو سي» قررت أنه نحتاج نقوّي هذه الخدمة
وراح تلاقي عمليات الاستحواذ هذه
فاستحوذتم أنتم عليهم
استحوذنا عليهم، فصار عندنا استراتيجيتين
عندنا التدقيق
التدقيق طبعًا فيه تدقيق خدمات استشارية للمخاطر
وفي ما نسميه التدقيق المالي
عندنا برضو الضريبة
فنسوي للشركات استشارات ضريبية خلينا نحكي
استشارات ضريبية
والامتثال
وبعض الأحيان نتعاون مع هيئة الزكاة
في استراتيجية تبعتها، واحتياجات البلد من هذا الموضوع
عندنا الرابعة اللي هي الصفقات
اللي احنا بنسميها بالإنقليزي (Deals)
أكثر الطَّرح العام الأولي اللي تشوفها في السعودية
«بي دبليو سي» بتعمل دور فيها
بتساعد في الطَّرح العام الأولي
وأنت مستشار الطَّرح؟
مستشار الطَّرح، نعم
عندك الاستحواذ، والتقييمات
الصفقات بيسووا هذه الخدمات
وفيه جزء قوي في الفترة الأخيرة في الصفقات
اللي هو بنسميه البنية التحتية للمشاريع الرأسمالية
اللي هي مشاريع البنية التحتية
سواءً من تقدير التكاليف
أو أنك تحط النموذج الأفضل لتنفيذ هذه المشاريع
وكيف تعمل خفض للتكلفة يعني أنك تنزل التكلفة للمشاريع
القسم الأكبر فيهم اللي هو الاستشارات
وهذه الاستشارات قطاعات
عندك قطاع خلينا نحكي الحكومي
وتحت القطاع الحكومي في الصحة والتعليم في عدَّة قطاعات
وعندك اللي احنا بنسميها الكفاءات
اللي هو مثلًا التكنولوجيا
التكنولوجيا هذه تتطرق لكل الصناعات الرقمية
تتطرق لأنا أيش أسوي في الصحة؟
أيش أسوي في القطاع العام الحكومي؟ وهكذا
هذه اللي احنا بنسميها الجدارات
وعندك إدارة التنفيذ
فلما تنظر إلى «بي دبليو سي» بصراحة
وأعتقد كثير من الشركات الأربعة الكبار
عندها هذه الإمكانية اللي هي أن احنا نبدأ من الاستراتيجية
لأن كثير ناس يقول لك الاستشاريين يسوّوا استراتيجية ويمشون
في الشركات هذه، يبدأ من الاستراتيجية، وينتهي في التنفيذ
احنا نسميها استراتيجية للتنفيذ
وبصراحة أنا شخصيًّا، عشان كذا ركزت حياتي على التنفيذ
لمّا تشتغل في التنفيذ، تستمتع فيه لأنك راح تشوف...
قطف الثمرة، صحيح
الثمرة
لمّا أكون أنا بس بسوّي على ورق غير. تحتاج لاستراتيجية
لأن بدون استراتيجية ما في شيء تنفذه
فهذا الهيكل تبع الشركة في الشرق الأوسط
وعشان أكمل التصور قبلما أدخل لعلاقتكم بالرؤية
الشريك اللي يكون موجود ضمن الـ 400
إذا ترك العمل تنتهي شراكته ما عاد يكون شريك
ما يأخذ جزء من الأرباح، ولا يستمر ولا...؟
تنتهي
تنتهي الشراكة؟
لو انتقل لشركة أخرى ولا شيء فهو تنتهي علاقته بكم
تنتهي، في طريقة للخروج من الشراكة
بس تنتهي، مش أنه هذه حصص وأنا ببيعها
ما يورثها عياله، لا خلاص؟
لا، ما يورث
فهي شراكة مهنية طالما هو يمارس المهنة في هذه الشركة
صحيح
يمكن، أبو بدر، من أكثر ملامح مرحلة الرؤية
هي مصطلح الشركات الاستشارية
وفي انقسام حاد جدًّا في المجتمع على دور هذه الشركات
جزء كبير، ما هو بسيط، يرى أن دورها سلبي
وعدَّة ممارسات راح نتطرق لها بعد شوي نسمع تعليقك
وجزء يرى أن دورها كان إيجابي جدًّا وجوهري في بناء أطر العمل
واستيراد النماذج الناجحة حول العالم، ومحاكاتها محليًّا
فخلينا نحكي أكثر عن دوركم في مرحلة التحول
خصوصًا وأنت اليوم، أبو بدر، شاهد على عمل الجهات الحكومية قبل الرؤية
في خلال عملك
وأنت اليوم جزء من العمل ما بعد الرؤية
تحديدًا أنت تعينت مسؤول عن مكتب السعودية
بعد ثلاثة أشهر من إطلاق الرؤية، فأنت معاصر بقرب لهذه المرحلة
طبعًا أنا، الحمد لله
كان لي الشرف أنه أشتغل على جزء من برنامج التحول الوطني
في هذيك الفترة
اليوم احنا في المثل هذا اللي يقول لك <<لا تعيد اختراع العجلة>>
المملكة العربية السعودية كانت متوجهة لرؤية، ما شاء الله
فأنت اليوم...
ومحطوط لها جدول زمني أعتبره عنيف
بس هذا اللي رؤسائنا، وحكامنا يعني...
كانت بهذه الصيغة أنه نبغى ننفذ
فما في مجال للغلط
وما في مجال لتضييع الوقت للتعلم
فأنت اليوم تقول أنا أبغى أبني هذا المبنى
تخيل أنه أنت ما أخذت أي خبرة من مباني ثانية
وتشوف وين الخبرات هذه
ما في شيء في العالم إلا تسوَّى تقريبًا
فأنت بتروح تشوف وين كان أفضل مكان
عُمل فيه هذه الخبرات أو عُمل فيه هذا المشروع
وكيف أنا أخذه وأحسن عليه
فدور الاستشاريين في الرؤية كان بصراحة حاجتين
أولاً، أنك تجيب الخبرة، وخبرات ما هي سهلة
ما شاء الله، الرؤية فيها توجهات جديدة علينا كلنا في المنطقة
وتحتاج خبرات
ومسؤولينا برضو على فكرة ما هم سهلين
لما يجلس معك يعرف أنه هذا الشخص عنده الخبرات، وعنده المسؤوليات
فإذا جبت هذه الخبرات، فهذا هدف أساسي من الشركات الاستشارية
وما بقول أنها مثالية إلا يكون في أغلاط هنا وهنا
ولكن الشيء الثاني اللي أنا أعتقد أنه أهم منه
أنه نقل المعرفة للشباب، والمواطن
فأعطيك مثال بسيط جدًّا
في بداية حياتي في تنفيذ المشاريع
كان في شيء اللي هو اسمه «بي أم أو»
مكتب إدارة المشاريع
لو أقول لك مكتب إدارة المشاريع أول ما بدأت أحكي في هذا الموضوع
زمان، من غير ما أحكي السنة
ما كان حد يعرف أيش هو
صح
الآن، وبعدين حتى لما جئنا للتنفيذ
قلنا: نبغى نبني القدرات على تدريب الشباب لتنفيذ المشاريع
أنت اليوم أيش يفيدك أن أنا أحط استراتيجية
مهما كانت جميلة هذه الاستراتيجية
إذا ما عندي طريقة أني أديرها وأنفذها
في عالم الاستراتيجية على ما يبدو
الأغلب لا يحول استراتيجيته إلى واقع
يا عيني عليك
هذا عُرف عالمي أن الاستراتيجيات تُبنى ثم تبقى في الدرج
فالتّحدي هو دائمًا في التنفيذ
100%
أنا هذا اللي خلاني أركز على التنفيذ
لأنه كنت وأنا في بداية مهنتي في الاستشارات
أشوف من عملائنا وثائق جميلة جدًّا كاستراتيجية
ودافعين عليها مبالغ، ومحطوطة على الدرج
فأنت زي اللي يقول أنا بخطط أنه أبني، وأسوي، وأعمل
وحاط الخطة بس ما سوّى فيها شيء
عشان كذا ركزت على التنفيذ
اليوم أقدر أقول لك أن السعودية في مجال إدارة المشاريع
يمكن من أفضل الدول في المنطقة وفي العالم
صار عندك أعداد الناس، ولغة التحدث والخبرات
اللي بتحكي في إدارة المشاريع ما هي نظري
فهذا مثال بسيط
على كيف أن الاستشاريين قدروا ينقلوا بعض المعرفة
وحطوا هذا النظام، خلينا نحكي، في إدارة المشاريع
عملية المتابعة
الشيء الثاني التدريب على القيادة
فأنا شخصيًّا، وزي ما قلت لك أنه ما هي مثالية
بس الإيجابيات من استخدام الخبرات
سهلت علينا، ووفرت على الدولة وقت
يمكن الناس ما راح يحسّوا فيه
أنه توفير الوقت أفضل، وأرخص، وأحسن تقدمًا
من أنك تقعد سنين، وما تنفذ شيء
فأنا شايفه إيجابي، ومُكمِّل
لأنه اليوم أنت كمان عشان نكون...
ما في كل السعة الموجودة
متوفرة عشان تنفذ كل هذه المشاريع، لازم تستعين
في العالم بصراحة الأيام هذه فيه تحدِّي أنك تجلب هذه الخبرات
فأن احنا الآن قادرين في السعودية
نجلب الخبرات اللي نطلبها، وننقلها عندنا هنا
على فكرة هذه شهادة أشهدها للسعودية
لأنه في دول ثانية يحاربوا على نفس الشيء
احنا «بي دبليو سي» هنا تُطالب بهذه الخبرات
في مكاتب ثانية في العالم تُطالب بنفس الخبرات
فأنه احنا نقدر نسحبهم لأنه الرؤية وصلت للعالم
فصار الكل يبغى يتحمس يكون جزء من هذا الـ...
ولو بتكلم بالأرقام، مكتب السعودية
عبارة عن كم موظّف، وكم السعوديين، كم...؟
احنا في السعودية، ولله الحمد، عندنا ستة مكاتب
يمكن من أكثر الشركات اللي عندها مكاتب
وإن شاء الله، المزيد قادم
وين مكاتبكم؟
عندنا مكتبين في الرياض، وعندنا مكتب في جدة
مكتب في الخبر، ومكتب الظهران، ومكتب في العُلا
وتقريبًا احنا اليوم، طبعًا هذا الرقم يطلع، وينزل
أعداد الموظفين فوق الـ 2300 موظف
تتكلم على فوق الـ 56% سعوديين
كم شريك في السعودية؟
في السعودية يتعدّو الـ 100
100 شريك؟
فوق الـ 100
كم منهم سعوديين؟
ما عندي العدد التقريبي
بس أبغى أقول: يمكن في حوالي خمسة عشر أو عشرين
15% هم سعوديين؟
سعوديين
أو عشرين
كلها مفهومة المكاتب إلا مكتب العُلا
غريب أنه فاتح مكتب في العُلا، أيش السر؟
ولا مأخذين عقد حلو معاهم؟
العُلا أولًا، احنا بدأنا مع العُلا من بدايتها
والعُلا أنا بالنسبة لي شخصيًّا، وللشركة
حسّينا أنه شعار الشركة أن نكون قريبين للمجتمعات
فالعُلا أعطتنا...
طبعًا شفنا توجه العُلا
وأخونا «عمر المدني» والدولة توجهها في العُلا
وشفنا الطموح، والحماس اللي بيصير في العُلا
فمن البداية اتفقنا أنه احنا ما راح نكون مستشار وعميل
احنا شركاء في هذا الموضوع
نحن الاثنين اتفقنا أننا نبغى نتعاون مع بعض في هذا الموضوع
واحنا عشان ندعم العُلا
من تدريب للمواطنين اللي عايشين هناك خارج عن المشاريع
أنه هذه المنطقة راح يصير فيها تغييرات كبيرة
راح يصير فيها مشاريع صغيرة كثيرة
والشركات الصغيرة، والمتوسطة
فدخلنا في مجال أنه ندرب، ونساعد فيها
كمسؤولية مجتمعية
مسؤولية مجتمعية
كم دربتم؟
الأعداد، درَّبنا، بجيب لك الأعداد بس ما هي معاي الآن
بس دربنا عدد كبير من رجال الأعمال اللي في العُلا
وزائد أننا في الاتفاق مع العُلا قلنا: احنا نبغى نعين كـ «بي دبليو سي»
ثلاثة عشر، احنا كان هدفنا عشرين
ثلاثة عشر شاب متخرج سعودي من العُلا نفسها
ونحطهم في «بي دبليو سي» يشتغلوا معنا لمدّة سنة
وإن شاء الله، يكونوا مهيئين ونرجعهم للعُلا مستشارين
فالشراكة هذه...
فأنت لما يكون في مشروع بهذا القبيل
شرف أنه أننا نفتح مكتب، ونكون قريبين على عملائنا في هذا الموضوع
وإن شاء الله، يارب في المشاريع الثانية نسوي شغلات قريبة منها
في مكاتب جاية وفروع زيادة؟
إن شاء الله
أنتم نقلتوا مقركم الإقليمي للرياض، صح؟
المقر الإقليمي في الرياض
وين كان، ومتى نقلتوه؟
شوف احنا أخذنا الرخصة في شهر خمسة
السنة هذه؟
السنة هذه، وأخذنا مكتب
الآن احنا من جهة المكاتب قاعدين نسوي مكتب رئيسي
يعني ما هو المقر الإقليمي
المقر الإقليمي يمكن يصير عندنا مكتب لموظفيننا
وتقريبًا، بإذن الله
راح يكون في الجهة القريبة من الحي الدبلوماسي
والمقر الإقليمي نفسه راح نحطه في المركز المالي، بإذن الله
المركز المالي
بس هذا المكتب اللي بيكون في...
احنا نسميه المكتب الرئيسي
راح يكون من أكبر المكاتب في الشرق الأوسط
فعليًّا أكبر مكتب في الشرق الأوسط
وراح يكون فيه خدمات جديدة علينا
مركز التجربة
شو بنسميها احنا التجربة؟
التجربة؟
التجربة، والابتكار والاختراعات
ونجيب عملاء ونعمل ورش عمل
الآن هو موجود في أماكن ثانية في العالم
وبنروح له ونأخذ بعض العملاء
نبغاه يكون في الرياض
وراح يكلفنا فلوس ما هي بسيطة
فلوسكم واجد، ما عليكم خوف، ما شاء الله
الله يسلمك
بس لا عن جد نبغى هذا المكتب يكون من أفضل المكاتب في المنطقة
وبرضو لما قلت مقر إقليمي
ترى كثير من الناس سمعوا الخبر بداية 2024
راح تكون في معاملة معينة للشركات
اللي مقرها الإقليمي ليس في الرياض
فلو تعرفنا أكثر أيش يعني مقر إقليمي؟
ومع مين تتعاملون؟
هل مع الهيئة الملكية وللَّا مع وزارة الاستثمار؟
أيش طبيعة الإجراء هذا؟
المتبنية للمقر الإقليمي هي وزارة الاستثمار
وأعتقد بالتعاون مع الهيئة الملكيّة للرياض
أكثر التعامل مع وزارة الاستثمار
أيش يعني مقر إقليمي؟
مقر إقليمي، أنت الآن لما تكون الشركة متواجدة في عدّة دول
صناع القرار، وين قاعدين؟
هل صناع القرار قاعدين في لندن؟
أو قاعدين في أي مكان في العالم
الدولة قالت نبغى صنّاع القرار، والمقر الإقليمي
والإدارة، المستوى سي خلينا نسميهم
العُليا تكون متواجدة في الرياض
وحطوا لها قوانين، ومراحل لهذا الموضوع
وطبعًا أنا شايفها شيء إيجابي جدًّا للبلد
لأنه كلما كانوا صنّاع القرار قاعدين قريبين على السوق
احنا لاحظنا أنا قاعد في الرياض
أنت نقلت الرياض؟
أنا مولود في الرياض
مولود في الرياض، مستقر هنا؟
مستقر هنا
يعني طيارة يوم الأربعاء حقّت دبي ما لك علاقة فيها؟
لا ما في منه، لا أنا من مواليد الرياض
وما دامك ذكرت الموضوع هذا
يعني الرياض لها مكانة كبيرة في قلبي
لما وُلدت في الرياض كان عدد سكان الرياض 290 ألف
تخيل هذا الموضوع؟
كيف متى وُلدت، ما شاء الله؟
ولا بلاش ندخل في السياسة؟
يعني خليني أقول في أواخر الستينيات
ما شاء الله
كان عدد سكان الرياض 290 ألف
أنت لما تشوف الرياض اليوم
ما شاء الله، بهذا الحجم اللي هي فيه
كُلنا فخورين بها، ولسّه
فالرياض بيت
فأنا لما قالوا أنه نبغى المكتب الإقليمي يكون في الرياض
يعني يا هلا، فهمت علي، بالعكس
واحنا فعلناها وحطينا المستوى سي اللي ما كانوا متواجدين في الرياض
المستوى سي اللي هم الرؤساء التنفيذيين
الرؤساء التنفيذيين
الأغلبية ترى في الرياض
بس اللي ما كانوا متواجدين في الرياض نقلناهم للرياض
كانت سلسة وللَّا؟
أيش أبرز تحدّي كان يمنع هؤلاء من الانتقال إلى الرياض؟
شوف، اليوم أنا لو أجي أقول لك أنت عايش في مكان متعود عليه
ولك نمط حياة وحياتك الاجتماعية
وعندك أصدقاءك، وأقاربك
وأقول لك معلش أنا بنقل المقر الإقليمي لمصر، القاهرة
أنت كشخص أترك...
هذه أعتقد اللي كانت من أصعب الحاجات
يعني أنا لو قالوا لي اليوم انقل لمكان ثاني
راح تكون صعبة علي
طبعًا هذه كان لها حوافز
وفي ناس اضطررنا أن نغير لهم دورهم لحاجات أو...
الأدوار
الدور تبعهم لشيء آخر
فأعتقد هذه كانت أصعب شيء، ما هي...
في شيء ثاني أعتقد أن، والدولة شغالين عليها
أنه الناس يخافوا على المدارس مثلًا
يعني اليوم حاط ابنه في مدرسة
خاصة إذا مرحلة متوسطة أو ثانوي
ويبغى ينقلوا من مكان لآخر
وتوفر المدارس الممتازة هذا مهم لهم
فيعني فيها تحديات أكثر على المستوى الاجتماعي
أكثر من أي شيء آخر
وكم زملائك اللي انتقلوا من المقر الإقليمي السابق إلى الرياض؟
طبعًا وزارة الاستثمار حاطَّة...
خطة تدريجية
خطّة
أعتقد الإطلاق كان طالب في بداية السنة خمسة عشر واحد
احنا تعدينا هذا الرقم
فخمسة عشر أنا بحكي عن الدرجة سي، وبعدين...
من أصل كم؟
شوف هي بتعتمد على كل شركة
صح
بالنسبة لحالتكم أنتم خمسة عشر من أصل كم؟
ما في، احنا الآن أهم شيء عندنا الرؤساء
أنت لا تنسى هذا إقليمي
أنت بتحكي على مركز إقليمي اللي هي الإدارة
إدارة لكل الشرق الأوسط
الإدارة يمكن ما تتعدى ثمانية عشر إلى عشرين
بس أنت بعدين تقرر اللي تحتهم متى أنقلهم؟
أنقلهم أو راح يضلوا؟
فهذه تعتمد على الـ...
بعض الناس قلقين من سهولة التحايل على هذا الشرط
لأنه صعب قياسه، وأيش يعني مقر القليمي؟
هل لو أنا ساكن وأروح عطلة نهاية الأسبوع هنا وأقعد هنا؟
من واقع تجربتكم، كيف عملية ضبط هذا الموضوع؟
بصراحة بالنسبة لنا احنا ما بنأخذ أي شيء...
أنه نبغى نسوي كذا عشان نرضي...
ولكن أنا من خبرتي في البلد أنه في تدقيق، وتتبع لهذه الأمور
ولكن عشان أكون كمان عادل
يعني أنت بتحكي على مركز إقليمي
هذول الناس راح يكونوا مسؤولين عن منطقة
فهو من واجبه...
يتنقل، ويتأكد
يتنقل، ويروح على هذه الدول يتأكد، والعمل سائر
فما أعتقد راح تكون سهلة اللعب بهذا الموضوع
بس أيش أهم معيار؟
هل هو مقر السكن أو الأسرة أو المدارس أو المكتب؟
أيش أهم معيار لقياس أن هذه الشركة فعلًا مقرها الإقليمي هنا
وللَّا ما هو هنا؟
أشوف أنا برأيي يمكن أهم معيار حجم الاستثمار في البلد
اليوم لما تشوف أنت شركة تستثمر كثير في البلد
سواءً من توظيف أو استثمارات ويصير منها استحواذات بالمستقبل
فهذا يتقيم طبعًا
قائمة التحقق أنه هذا موجود أو مش موجود راح تبين هذه
بس هي حتى لو أنا اليوم قاعد في الرياض
وماني قاعد أستثمر في الرياض، أيش استفدت أنت؟
فأنا برأيي بالأخير هي طبعًا وجودهم أكيد 100%
وبالتالي أنه حجم الاستثمار، الالتزام للبلد
هذه أعتقد صعبة أنك تقيسها بس راح تبين من الأفعال
أنا يمكن أبغى أنتقل، يا أبو بدر، لجزء مهم من هذه الحلقة
اللي هو أهم المآخذ أو الملاحظات أو المفاهيم
المتداولة عن الشركات الاستشارية، وأخذ تعليقك عليها
يمكن أبدأ بحديث للأمير «عبد العزيز بن سلمان» الله يحفظه
وزير الطاقة
أدرت معه جلسة حوارية في مؤتمر مسك العام الماضي
المنتدى العالمي مسك
وكان يقول أنا ضد التوسع في الاستعانة بشركات استشارية
لأنها مخاطرة في ذاكرة المنشأة نفسها
لما تكون كل الخبرة والتاريخ والمعرفة عند فريق رحَّال
هو يجي ويشتغل على المشروع ثم يختفي
أنا قاعد أغامر بإرث كامل لهذه المؤسسة
فهو كان عنده رأي جدًا صارم في هذا الموضوع
فأيش رأيك على جزئيّة
أن الشركات الاستشارية هي حل سريع ومريح
لكنه يُهدر ذاكرة المنشآت
ويتسبب في تسرُّب المعرفة، والتاريخ حق هذه المنشآت؟
الشركات الاستشارية لازم يكون في تقييم
ليش احنا بنجيب الشركات الاستشارية؟
أنا بقول الشركات تُجاب لما تكون الخبرة غير متوفرة
وخبرة جديدة على المنشأة
ما في قدرات متوفرة أو السعة لهذه...
يعني مش لازم نجيب الشركات الاستشارية لحاجات متوفرة
إذا الخبرات موجودة عندي
وأنا كمنظمة أو كجهة سوِّيت هذه المشاريع ما في داعي أنه...
بس مو هذا اللي قاعد يصير
الممارسة اللي قاعدين نشوفها اليوم في الجهات الحكومية
ابتداءً من 2015 أنه فيه إسراف في الاستعانة بالشركات الاستشارية
من وجهة نظر الكثيرين
فشيء مهم، وحتى بعضهم كان يعيّن سكرتير من شركة استشارية
ويوميته 8000 - 9000 ريال، اليومية حقته
وهو راتبه في السوق يمكن يوميته 1000 ريال
فاحنا نتكلم على سوء استخدام الاستعانة بالشركات الاستشارية
هذه ممارسات موجودة، وأنت متطلع عليها وللَّا لا؟
يعني أنه سكرتير من شركات استشارية، هذه جديدة علي
ما قد شفت الحالة هذه؟
ما قد شفت الحالة
ولكن طبعًا هو الغلط يجي من الطرفين
إذا الجهة يعني لأي شيء تجيب استشاري
والشركة الاستشارية ما بتقيم القيمة
أنا اليوم كـ «بي دبليو سي»
أحتاج أني أشوف أنا أيش القيمة اللي بضيفها لك
ما هو أي مشروع الشركات...
يعني تقول لأشياء لا؟ ما أظن تقول
إذا العميل يقول لك بدفع لك المبلغ هذا، ما أظن تقول له: لا
لا، في أشياء أكيد احنا راح نقول لا، كثير نقول لا
مثل؟ أقصد أيش الأشياء اللي ترفضونها؟
احنا أصلًا عندنا طريقة للتقييم
بنسميها هل نذهب أم لا؟
عندنا لجنة
هذه اللجنة إذا هذا المشروع ما له قيمة للعميل
سمعتنا أهم من...
هل معناه كل الشركات بتعمل هذا؟ الله أعلم
فأنا قصدي كنصيحة أنه لازم نجيب الشركات الاستشارية
في المكان اللي يضيفوا قيمة فيه
ما هو أي...
هل الغلطات موجودة؟ أكيد موجودة، لا شك
فهذه من جهة
الآن إذا أنا جبت الشركة الاستشارية على مشروع اللي أنا راح أستفيد منه
الخبرات ما هي متوفرة عندي، ولا السِعة موجودة عندي
لازم أنا كجهة، ولازم أنا كشركة استشارية
أقول: كيف عملية نقل المعرفة؟
يعني اليوم زي ما أنت ذكرت أخوي عمر
إذا اليوم أنا جئت، وسويت المشروع وخلصته، وأمورك تمام
وأنت ما استفدت من هذه الخبرة من موظفينك؟ خسارة
غلطة مين هذه؟
الاثنين
لأنه أنت لازم تطالب أنه أنا أبغاك، وأنت طالع
وعلى فكرة العملاء في السعودية، بالذات الجهات الحكومية
من سنين أنا أشايفهم الأغلبية
يقول لك أهم شيء عندي نقل المعرفة
نقل المعرفة
وكيف يكون شكل نقل المعرفة؟
وثائق وتتسلم وبس، وللَّا كفاءات تُدرب؟
لا، إذا وثائق هذه كتب نقرأها كلها
صح
الطريقة أنك تحط مُتعقِّبين
تحط ناس اللي يشتغلوا مع الاستشاريين
بدها استثمار أولها
فيه تدريب نظري، والتدريب الفعلي اللي هو التَّعقب
الطريقة الوحيدة أنا شفتها أنه الناس تشتغل
القراءة والمحاضرة هذه بتعطيك مدخل للمجال
بس هذول أفضل شيء
عشان كذا أنا أعطيتك مثال قبل شوي
أنه في العُلا عيَّنا احنا «بي دبليو سي»
شوف نقل المعرفة
عيَّننا ثلاثة عشر واحد، والآن، إن شاء الله، سنعيِّن كمان
راح يشتغلوا معانا كـ«بي دبليو سي» لمدة سنة
من أبناء العُلا؟
من أبناء العُلا
وبعدين ينتقلون إلى الهيئة؟
ينتقلوا لها عشان نساعد في...
لأنه هذه الخبرة ما هي متوفرة كثير في السوق المحلِّي في العُلا
فعشان كذا لازم نصير نفكر في كل مشروع
كيف أنقل هذه المعرفة؟
أنا لما كنت...
بيسموها «كبير المستشارين»
يعني أعتبر جديد بهذيك الأيام
أنا متذكر واحد من عملائنا
كانوا عندنا فريق خبراء من بريطانيا
وقال لي: رياض
هذا زي ما تقول من الموجهين من الناس اللي أحترمهم كثير
أنت الآن لازم تكون زي الإسفنجة
كيف الإسفنجة تشرب الماء؟ أنت اشرب العلم
وفعلًا فأنت كل الخبرات هذه
فأنا بقول لأي جهة بتستخدم استشاريين
فرصتك تستثمر، وتعلم شبابك بالواقع
لأنه مرة مرتين، وبعدين لازم الشباب يسوُّوها لحالهم
وفي برضو ممارسة ثانية مرتبطة بالجهات الحكومية
أو بعض الجهات أنها تبغى الختم
أكيد أنك سمعت أنت المعلومة هذه
أنه في جهة راح تقدم أو في مسؤول خلينا نقول
راح يقدم على مديره ملف
عشان ما يتحمل مسؤوليته أيش بيصير في هذا الملف
جيب واحدة من الأسماء اللامعة، وخليها تعطيك الختم
وفعليًّا الشركات الاستشارية تجي، وتسمع من الموظفين المشكلة
ثم تسمع من الموظفين الحلول
وتجيب لها شوية من القطاع الخاص ببلاش
تسوي معهم ورشة عمل، وتأخذ منهم حلول
وترتب هذا كله في شرائح عرض كويسة
وتعتبر أنه هذه هي المُخرج حقها، وتأخذ عليه ملايين
فوين القيمة المضافة في هذا النوع من المشاريع؟
شوف طبعًا احنا ما نقدر نعمم على هذا الموضوع
اليوم أنت لو تروح لدكتور
هل الدكتور راح يقول لك أنت...
مش أنت لازم يسألك الدكتور؟ هذا جزء من التشخيص
فاليوم الدكتور راح يقول لك: أيش شعورك هنا؟
كم درجة الحرارة؟ كم كذا؟ نمت كويس أو لا؟
جزء من الاستشارة، يمكن هذا فيه سوء فهم
جزء من الحلول، أنه أنا أفهم وين المشكلة؟
فجزء من إطار العمل
إطار العمل
إطار عمل الشركات الاستشارية
أول خطوة يجي يقول لك فيها أبغى أسوي تحليل للوضع الحالي
التحليل للوضع الحالي يتطلب الجلوس معك، ويفهم أيش القصص
أيش المشاكل اللي تواجهها، وأيش الـ...؟
الآن جزء من هذا العمل يرجع إلى الممارسة الأفضل
وللخبراء كمان بعض الأحيان، ويطلع بالحل المفترض
للأسف لمّا ما نكون فاهمين طرق وإطار العمل هذا
النظرة راح تكون أنه هذول ييجوا يأخذوا اللي أنا أقوله
ويرجع يكتب لي إياه، ويعطيني إيّاه
طبعًا هذه سامعها من ثلاثين أو أربعين سنة مش بس عندنا
برّى في...
بس هذه لعدم الفهم من...
اليوم الدكتور نفسه شغَّال على طريقة عمل معينة
بناءً على خبرته راح يقول، وبناءً على التّحاليل هذه
أنا عندي هذه الأدوية أو هذه الخطوات اللي لازم تعملها
فالشركات هذه العالمية أنا بس عشان أكون صريح مع...
يعني أكون واقعي
الشركات العالمية اسمها هذا والعلامة التجاريّة مهم جدًّا بالنسبة لها
فمستحيل يجي إذا هي شركة عالمية
ويختم على شيء ما هو مقتنع فيه
أو شيء ما هو عمل عليه الدراسة الصحيحة، لأنه سمعته
أنت عارف يعني الآن العالم تبعنا
وحتى احنا في «بي دبليو سي» بداية هذا الكلام مبني على الثقة
اليوم احنا كلمة التدقيق، والختم تبع «بي دبليو سي»
بناءً على ثقة
فلما أنا أجي اليوم كمدقّق حسابات
وأجي أقول أنه هذه ختم «بي دبليو سي» أنه هذه الحسابات كذا وكذا
مسؤولية كبيرة هذه
هل في أخطاء في في الـ...؟
أنا متأكد في أخطاء، ما في أحد كامل
بس أنا أقول لك إياها من خبرتي، ومن اللي شفته
أنه ما في أحد يجلس، ويأخذ الكلام، ويكتبه على ورق، ويأخذ عليه ملايين
احنا عملائنا أذكياء وناس فهمانة
فهي جلب الخبرات
نفهم الوضع الحالي
وبعدين أرجع لك بتوصيات مبنية على مئات السنين من الخبرات
وخبراء من حول العالم الممكن يفتوا في هذا الموضوع
أنه هذه أفضل طريقة لتعالج المشكلة الموجودة
وعشان نفهم لأنه هذا يمكن يكون أكثر مثال
ويمكن يكون أتوقع الاستشارات هي أكبر مصدر
من مصادر دخلكم وللا لا حاليًا في السعودية؟
صحيح
فهذا أكثر نموذج مستخدم بالذات مع القطاع الحكومي
هو العميل الأكبر لكم
أعطينا مثال، إذا تقدر تذكر الاسم يا سلام
إذا ما تقدر، أفهم حساسية بعض المشاريع
لكن أبغى أفهم دورة حياة مشروع من أول ما طرح
كيف أنتم تنافستم عليه، وفزتوا فيه
ومراحل العمل إلى مرحلة التسليم، والمغادرة
أو إذا كان في نهاية أخرى
ودنا نأخذ دورة الحياة كاملة
طيب أنا راح أذكر مشروع من غير ما أحكي الاسم
هذا المشروع كان فيه استراتيجية
اشغلت عليها عدّة شركات، وهي من الهيئات الموجودة في الدولة
وما فيها أحد
الآن هذه الهيئة ستقام، وما في إللَّا خطة استراتيجية
هيئة جديدة توها
هيئة جديدة
هذا الكلام طبعًا من عدّة سنوات
ودور «بي دبليو سي» كان أنه تعال فعلوا هذه الجهة
فوضعت الخطط اللازمة للتفعيل
وكان فيه أدوار إذا ما هي متوفرة
ووضعت خطة للتعيين من الرئيس التنفيذي
ومن الجهات الموجودة
بس آسف أيش كانت المناقصة، عبارة عن أيش؟
أيش مسمى المناقصة؟
تفعيل
بناء، تشغيل، ونقل
ونوعية المشاريع هذه ممتازة جدًّا لأنها راح تورِّيك القيمة
بس صعبة جدًّا لأنه تبغى تشغِّل بسرعة
فلعبنا أدوار بعض المراكز في الهيئة
وكل مركز من يتعين عليه، ونحط طبعًا الخطة
فأنتم سوِّيتوا الهيكل؟
الهيكل التنظيمي
استقطبتم الأشخاص؟
مثلًا خليني أعطيك مثال، عندك الموارد البشرية
السياسات، والإجراءات لشؤون الموظفين
السياسات والإجراءات أو العمليات الإجرائية للمحاسبة
التكنولوجيا
هذا كله داخلي عشان أنت تجهز
وهذه الهيئة نفسها كانت بتسوي عمليات خارجية
يعني أنها تبدأ في العمل الخارجي
لمدّة تقريبًا سنة ونص، وكل فترة
كلمّا كنا يتعين أشخاص معنا نطلع من الـ...
ففي البداية موظفينكم هم اللي كانوا معبين
بدأت تنشأ هذه الهيئة
والآن اليوم هيئة من أكبر الهيئات
يعني ما فيها «بي دبليو سي» الحمد لله
يمكن فيها فوق 800 موظف اليوم
ومن الهيئات المتطورة، واحنا غير متوجدين فيها الآن
فهي بناء الهيئة نفسها...
الخطة الاستراتيجية للهيئة
وتعيين الموظفين، وبناء القوائم المالية
بناء تكنولوجيا المعلومات، وبناء كل المهمات
أو كل العمليات اللي تحتاجها الهيئة للتنفيذ
وبنفس الوقت كانت تطلع تغييرات
كانت في أشياء جديدة تطلع
أحداث معينة تصير في نفس الهيئة
ما كان مخطط لها صدقًا
بس كانت مهمة جدًّا
فتدخلوا، وتنفذوا بعدين تطلعوا
لو أخذنا هذا المثال، أبو بدر
خلينا نرجع نتحدى شوية المثال هذا
بأننا نقول: وين الجديد في الموضوع؟
ما هي أول هيئة نأسسها، وما هو بأول هيكل يتسوَّى
الموارد البشريَّة، والسياسات والإجراءات
هي نفسها موجودة في أغلب الجهات
ليش أحتاج أجيب شركة استشاريَّة؟
أنا عندي عشرات الهيئات
أقدر أستفيد من تجربتها في أني أسس هذه الهيئة
بدون أن أدفع هذه الملايين للشركات الاستشارية
وين القيمة المضافة حقتكم؟
أنا أقول لك، ممتاز السؤال
طبعًا، اليوم أنت...
هذا السؤال لما يُطرح بهذه الطريقة
يَفترض أنه كل هذه القدرات موجودة
ولا تشتغل تحت نظام اللي يديرها، وينفذها مع بعض
ولا تحت نظام اللي يكون مهيأ لطلبات العميل، والأمور هذه
موجودة
أعطيك بنفس هذا المشروع اللي أنا ذكرت لك إياه
طُلب مشروع من أعلى الجهات
لنفس هذه الهيئة يتنفذ خلال خمسة وخمسين يوم
وما في مجال أنك...
الحدث هذا عالمي كان
ما هو حدث أنك تغير التاريخ، ولا تتأخر بيوم أو يومين
هل لو أنت في القرار أو في المنصب هذا
راح تأخذ المخاطر أنه أنفذ وللَّا ما أنفذ؟
القيمة أنه الشركات هذه أو شركتنا في ذلك الوقت
أعطت ضمانات بالخبرات اللي جاءت، وسوَّت هذا الموضوع
طبعًا هم أول ما جاؤوا قالوا خمسة وخمسين يوم
وين أنتم يا...
ولكن تنفذ
فالقيمة المضافة هنا كانت الوقت؟
الوقت والخبرات اللي بتيجي
اليوم جبنا للمحاسبة، أنت بتقول هذه موجودة
صحيح
ولكن الهيئات، والقوانين، واللوائح
كانت تتغير في نفس الوقت
فاحنا جبنا الناس اللي فاهمه المالية، ووزارة المالية كيف تشتغل
فأنت اليوم الشركة هذه تنظر لها
أنه عندك جميع أو عندك خبرات كثيرة اللي أقدر أستخدمها
إذا أنا اليوم هيئة جديدة، إذا متوفرين الموظفين
ومتوفرين يسوّوا كل هذا الشغل
لا تجيب شركات استشارية
هي كانت كيف أسرع عملية إنشاء هذه الهيئة
وتفعيلها، وتسليمها وامشي
ونوعية هذه المشاريع تسعيرتها على فكرة غير عن...
بس لأنك قلت نصرف الملايين
أسعار المشاريع اللي زي هذه بناء، وتشغيل، ونقل
مختلفة نهائيًّا عن المشاريع الاستراتيجية
لأنه نوعية القدرات، بالذات لما تيجي للتشغيل
التشغيل هذا يومًا بعد يوم
فهذه غير لأنه هذول أشخاص مختلفين عن اللي بيسووا الاستراتيجية
والأمور هذه
ما دام جبت طاري التكلفة، وحدة برضو من التساؤلات
على كيف تسعرون؟
لأنه أنتم أغلب النموذج حقَّكم يعتمد على يوميَّة المستشار
أو يوميّة الشريك
سولفت مع أحد يعمل في شركة من الشركات الاستشارية
قال لي أنا أعرف أن ساعتي تُسعر بعشرة أضعاف راتبي
مثلًا نفترض أنه راتبه 30 ألف
تسعر خدمته بـ 300 ألف لدى الجهة
أيش سبب هذا التضخم الهائل؟
طبعًا هو ما يستلم الفارق هذا، وين قاعد يروح؟
الشركاء، الله يبارك لكم، ولا وين يروح؟
لا ياريت، خليني، هذه نقطة مهمة بصراحة
جدًّا
اليوم عندك في تكاليف للشركات الاستشارية
تكاليف بحوثات، أنا ذكرت لك مكاتب، ومركز تجربة، ومركز العميل
في بحوثات تصير على مستوى العالم
في أنظمة، وتكاليف لأنك تشغل شركة بهذا الحجم
تكاليف من بحوثات، وخبراء، تكاليف من هذا...
هذه اليوم، رياض راح يكلفني إكس
فالشركات هذه بتيجي بتقول أنا تكلفة كل هذا الدعم اللي بيصير
عشان رياض يكون، وتتقسم العدد من الموظفين
فكلما زاد عدد الموظفين...
على فكرة المفروض أنه طبعًا هي بتزيد شوي التكلفة
بس المفروض أنه التكاليف الغير مباشرة خلينا نسميه
يقل
فهذه التكلفة التسويق، وكل وظائف الدعم
تُحط فوق تكلفة الشخص، ويحط عليها الهامش
عشان كذا تبين في كل المشاريع أعلى بكثير
أنا هذا جبته، وراح أدفع له؟ طبعًا
بس هذا الشخص اللي قاعد قدامك
وراءه جيش، وبحوثات، وأنظمة، ومعرفة
عنده وصول لكل الخبراء فكل هذا له ثمن
يمكن الناس يشوفوها أنها مرتفعة جدًّا
بس بصراحة
إذا ما حطوا هذه الاستثمارات في هذه الأنظمة والمعرفة والبحوثات
ما نقدر نفيد العملاء بالطريقة اللي احنا نفيدها
وبشكل عام القطاع كم الهامش فيه؟
تختلف ما تقدر...
كمتوسط؟
لا ما تقدر، لأنه من خدمة لخدمة تختلف نهائيًّا
أنت بالتدقيق غير عن...
في الاستشارات
حتى في الاستشارات
أيش المدى حقكم؟
يعني لا يقل عن كذا ولا يزيد عن كذا، أيش المدى؟
ما عندي هذه المعلومة لأنها زي ما حكيت لك
متوزعة كثير على الخدمات، يعني التكنولوجيا غير عن الاستشارة
بصراحة ماني عارف أطلع لك في مدى
وكثير من الأحيان احنا، للأسف خليني أحكي لك هذه نقطة مهمة
في توجه احنا لنا فترة بنحكي فيه
وأعتقد هذا اللي يمكن يساعد في المستقبل
كيف الاستشارات تستفيد منها الجهات الخاصة
اللي هو احنا بنسميه الترتيب على أساس القيمة
يعني أنا اليوم الشركة الاستشارية لما أجيبها
أتوقع مخرجات أعمال، وهذه المخرجات ما أحكي على ورق أنا
مخرجات خلينا نقول تنقيص تكلفة الإمداد بمبلغ معين
النتائج اللي تقدر تعملها
اليوم مستعدين كثير من الشركات الاستشارية، تقول لك يصير تحاسبني على النتائج
أعتقد هذا التوجه في المستقبل لازم يكون هو القائم
احنا نسويه في بعض الأماكن
بس مش الكل...
ونظام الشراء بعض الأحيان ما يكون فيه هذه الخدمة
ولا أكثر هذه الشركات مستعدة تيجي تقول...
وهذا اللي أعتقد أنت تعرف الجاد من النّظري
أنه اليوم أنا أبغى أوفر تكاليف الشغيل في الجهة 50% أو 40% أو 80%
وبنفس الوقت أبغى أحسِّن الخدمة
الشركات تجي تسوي دراستها
تيجي تقول لك تعال أنا مستعد أني أسوِّي هذا المشروع
وتدفع لي حسب النتائج
الآن في جهات كثيرة في الدول في أمريكا
بدأوا يتجهوا لهذا الموضوع
أنا أتوقع أنه احنا لازم نتوجه بهذا التوجه في المستقبل
يمكن مش في مرحلة التحويل
لأنه بيكون عندنك بيانات معينة تعرف بالضبط أين...
فأنا أتمنى أن أكون شرحت موضوع كيف تُحسب التكلفة
لأن هذا السؤال على فكرة من وأنا صغير، وهو يجيني هذا السؤال
يا رياض أنت لو جبت لك كذا...
صحيح
الفرق أنه بيجيك رياض
بس لما يجيك رياض باسم «بي دبليو سي»
معناها «بي دبليو سي» جالسة تدعمه بكل المعرفة، والمعلومات
وكل الاستثمارات اللي حطَّتها في هذا الشخص
بما أننا تكلمنا أيضًا على بعض الملاحظات
أو المآخذ على الشركات الاستشارية
واحد من أهمها وأكثرها حساسية هو موضوع تعارض المصالح
أو سوء استغلال البيع المتبادل
فيه زميل قاعد يسوي تدقيق على شركة
وجنبه في المكتب زميل قاعد يقدم استشارة
للجهة الحكومية اللي تُشرف على هذه الشركة
شفنا حالة ظهرت للإعلام
نشرتها «الجارديان» حالة الفساد في «بي دبليو سي» أستراليا
لما بعض الشركاء اللي عندهم استشارات مع الجهة الضريبية
سربوا معلومات لزملاءهم اللي في الشركات التدقيق
وكان على إثرها عدّة تداعيات
اليوم نفس الحالة هنا كأسس، خلينا نقول
أنه فيه قطاع مهم قاعد يدخل مع كل الجهات الحكومية
يقدم لهم استشارات، وفيه قطاع جنبه قاعد يقدم تدقيق
لشركات تتعامل مع هذه الجهات
كيف نتجنب حدوث فساد في هذه الحالة؟
طبعًا، احنا دائمًا ما نسمع إلا لما يصير مشكلة
ولكن ما نفهم أن هذا الموضوع قائم بكل أماكن العالم
اللي هو شركة زي «بي دبليو سي» والشركات الأربعة الكبيرة
أنها بتشتغل بهذا، ولها معايير قاسية جدًّا
اللي احنا بنسميها الاستقلال، والامتثال
فبس على موضوع أستراليا
هذا الموضوع الشركة أخذته بكل جدِّية
ومع أنه التأثير على فكرة اللي سمعناه احنا من أستراليا
الإعلام الغربي بشكل عام، أنت تعرف، تضخيم للأمور
مش أنه احنا نستهتر بهذا الموضوع
احنا أنه في الشرق الأوسط طبعًا
القناة الأولى، والقناة الثانية احنا بنسميهم
اللي هي استشارات وتدقيق
هذه سمعتنا
يعني قوانين الشركة والاختبارات والتدريبات
والامتثال اللي بيصير على هذا الموضوع
ما هو بس بيد الشرق الأوسط، وللَّا يد رياض
في عالميًّا لأن هذا اسم الشركة
فكل شيء تتخيله اليوم
اعطني أمثلة، كيف فاصلين بينهم؟
كيف تضمنون عدم تسرب المعلومات من هنا وهنا؟
احنا أول شيء التدقيق أكثر ناس، ولله الحمد، مركزين على القناة
احنا ما بنشتغل بنفس الـ...
القناة الأولى خلينا نسميها اللي هو الجوهر
نفس المبنى أنتم؟
نفس المبنى بس أنا قصدي الاستشارات اليوم
ما بتشتغل في أي عميل قناة أولى
وهذا قانون البلد على فكرة
في السعودية، نظام البلد في السعودية
ولله الحمد، من أحسن الأنظمة
في بعض الدول تسمح أنك حتى لو أنت بتسوي التدقيق
ممكن تسوِّي بعض الخدمات الاستشارية
احنا هنا يا أبيض يا أسود
فأنا شركة ثمانية إذا موقع مع «بي دبليو سي» تدقيق مالي
ما بشتغل معك
مستحيل آخذ أي عقد مع الاستشارات
بالضبط
مستحيل
خاصة إذا أنت جهة عامّة
إي إذا شركة عامّة
شركة عامّة
طيب إذا شركة خاصَّة مسموح أو غير مسموح؟
احنا قانون الشركة غير مسموح
أنا بحكي من نظام البلد
لأنه نظام البلد يعتمد إذا الشركة عامة وللَّا مش عامة
بس أنتم داخليًّا هذه سياسة صارمة ما فيها...؟
يا نسوي تدقيق يا استشارات
هذه جيدة فيما يخص القطاع الخاص
لكن حكومة كمُشرع، والشركات المتأثرة بهذه التشريعات
طيب، اليوم احنا بندقق أرامكو
ما نسوي اي مشروع في أرامكو استشارات
وشوف حجم أرامكو وحجم الاستشارات اللي تحتاجه
ما نخلط بين الأمور سواءً حتى لو الجهات الحكومية
الشيء الوحيد اللي بنسويه في الجهات الحكومية
تحت اللي احنا بنسميه القناة الأولى
ولكن هو بصراحة استشارات
استشارات ضريبية
لا، الضريبية أو إدارة المخاطر، فهمت علي، لأن ما هي تدقيق
فالاستشارات الضربية ما تشتغل مع هيئة الزكاة
لما تكون على قوانين، وسياسات من هذا النوع
أنت يا هنا يا هنا ما تقدر تشتغل في الطرفين
ولكن إذا أصدرت الهيئة قوانين
نساعد الشركات في كيف تعمل التقارير
والأمور اللي تخص الموضوع هذا
على العموم...
صارت حالات معينة تعاملتوا معها بحزم في «بي دبليو سي» أو السعودية
أنه فيه سوء استغلال لمعلومات أو إفشاء سرية؟
لا، في هذا الموضوع
ما صارت حالة؟
لا
لأنه صراحةً أنا مثلًا أقيس على نفسي
ألاحظ كذا مرة بالذات في فترة 2016-2015
لما كان فيه كثافة استشاريين ييجون من دبي
الأحد الصباح، ويرجعون الأربعاء
كان يؤلمني جدًّا أن أشوف جانبي الاستشاري
في البدلة حقته فاتح اللابتوب
وقاعد يشتغل على ملفات في غاية السرِّية تخص جهة حكومية
أنا قاعد أشوف المعلومات قدامي
قاعد هذا الشخص
بكل لا مبالاة وإهمال يعمل عليها في مكان عام
صح
ففي تسريبات كثيرة صارت
ويمكن أكيد أنت اتطلعت على حالات معينة أو ملف معين
فجأة نلاقيهم يتداولون على الواتساب، شلون؟
عن طريق واحدة من الشركات الاسشارية
فحساسية، وسرية المعلومات ودِّي أعرف أكثر
أيش الإجراءات المتبعة داخليًّا لضبطها، وحمايتها؟
أولًا احنا في «بي دبليو سي» عندنا صارمة
عن جد صارمة لدرجة بعض الأحيان أنا شخصيًّا بتعب منها
يعني اليوم، لو أنا معاي جهازي لـ«بي دبليو سي»
وأبغى أعطيك وثائق
أي شلون؟
ما أقدر كله محمي، ومشفر والأمور هذه
هذه من جهة، فالتكنولوجيا عندنا اليوم
أي بريد إلكتروني حتى اللي تُصدر من الموظفين
لوين يروح رسائل البريد الإلكتروني؟
إذا هي خارج عن النطاق
وأيش هي المعلومات؟ إذا في أي...
بعض الأحيان أعطيك مثال أيش يصير
يكون عميل بجهة حكومية طالب من الموظف
ارسل لي البريد الإلكتروني هذا على الجي ميل
ييجي عندنا عَلَم في النظام
وأنت وين رايح؟
فهمت علي؟
هذه نوع من أنواع الشفرات على السايبر
لأنه احنا زي ما حكيت لك جزء الثقة بصراحة إذا أنت حطيت الثقة
أن عملائي لازم يثقوا فيَّ
لازم أسوي كل شيء اللي يثق فيّ
فأنت راح تصير تدخل في كل سلوك للناس
أو طريقة التعامل الموظفين، والمعلومات
سرية المعلومات، هذه واحدة
ثانيًا: كل سنة كل موظفين الشركة عندهم تدريب افتراضي
يعني يدخل في نظام، واختبار ويعملوا له سيناريو
أنه تارك اللابتوب، وما هو معمول له قفل
يعني لها الدرجة، ويجب أن ينجح في هذا الاختبار
وإذا ما عمله ينفصل من الشركة هذا المتدرب الموجود
توعية
هل معناه هذه سكّرت كل المنافذ؟ أكيد لا
بس المعلومات خاصة اللي لها علاقة...
وطبعًا من عميل لعميل تفرق
يعني سرية المعلومات لجهة حكومية
لجهة عامَّة تختلف من جهة لجهة
ولكن في قانون صارم على هذا الموضوع في «بي دبليو سي»
وأنا أتوقع كل الشركة، بصراحة
أكثر الشركات العالمية، وبالذات أنا خليني أردد على الأربعة الكبار
لأن هذا اللي أقدر أحكيه لأنه تقريبًا نفس السياسة
راح تلاقيهم عندهم قانون صارم على سرية المعلومات
التكنولوجيا واستخدام التكنولوجيا
أيش المعلومات اللي تستخدم؟
أنا أعتقد كمان من مجتمعنا، للأسف
اليوم كثير نستخدم الواتساب
صحيح
فهمت علي، فهي من الطرفين
ولازم نصير ننتبه على أيش المعلومات اللي لما تطلب على الواتساب تُرسل
وما دامك تطرقت لموضوع الأربعة الكبار
أحس جميل لو رسمت لنا خارطة الشركات الاستشارية، وتصنيفها
لأن الظاهر فيه الثلاث الكبار هذول اللي هم التصنيف الاول
بعدين في الأربعة الكبار هذول التصنيف الثاني
شوف ما في الثلاث الكبار والأربعة الكبار
اللي هم «ماكنزي» و«بي سي جي»
هذول هم عادةً استراتيجي ما يدخلوا في الإقصاء
نعم خليني...
وهذول مرحلة قبلكم عادةً
لما أنا أحكي الأربعة الكبار هذول الشركات اللي فيها تدقيق
هذول أكبر أربعة شركات في العالم
اللي هم نذكر فيهم «ديلويت»
«ديلويت» و«إي آي» و«كي بي إم جي» و«بي دبليو سي»
حلو
هذه الشركات أو خلينا أحكي لأنه أنا أعرف عن «بي دبليو سي»
«بي دبليو سي» عندها استراتيجي للإقصاء
فأنتم تجوا في المرحلة اللي بعد «بي سي جي» و«ماكنزي»؟
لا
لا تنسى أننا لدينا خدمة «استراتيجي آند»
«استراتيجي آند» هي «بوز آند كومباني»
وهي «ماكنزي» و«بي سي جي»
«بي سي جي» و«ماكنزي» وكلها شركات عالمية
تاريخيًّا معروف عنهم تطوير الاستراتيجيات
ولكن مؤخرًا احنا نشوفهم في التنفيذ أيضًا
فكلها شركات عالمية
نوعية الشركة مختلف
لأن مثلًا زي «ماكنزي» و«بي سي جي» ما عندهم خدمات ضريبية
ما عنده التدقيق، ما هو مصرح له في هذا الموضوع
هذا الفرق، وطبعًا لما تيجي أنت الآن إلى الشركات الاستراتيجية
اللي تطور الاستراتيجية، في الطبقة الأولى والطبقة الثانية
هذول مختلفين عن الأربعة الكبار
الأربعة الكبار هو زمان على وقتي كان فيه الثمانية الكبار للتدقيق
كان أربع شركات عالمية اللي تسوِّي التدقيق في العالم
وعمّالهم يصغروا للستة وأربعة، الله يستر
السعودية صايرين الثلاثة الكبار هم تقريبًا صح؟
في واحدة مستبعدة كانت عن سوق المال
برضو على طاري «ماكنزي» والشركات هذه
شفنا خطوة احنا كانت مثيرة
استحواذ «ماكنزي» على «الإكسير» شركة استشارات محلية
هذا في 2015 أو 2016 في الوقت هذا
كيف تُقيم الخطوة هذه؟
وكيف تصف طبيعة علاقتكم مع الشركات الاستشارية المحلية؟
هل هم منافس أو مكمل، هم في دوري مختلف تمامًا بعيد عنكم؟
أيش تعلق على هذا الموضوع؟
طبعًا أنا أعتقد «ماكنزي» «لأكسير» كانت خطوة ممتازة
يمكن الأهم بهذه الخطوات أنه عملية الاندماج
احنا استحواذنا على عدة شركات كـ«بي دبليو سي» في المنطقة
في شيء منها في السعودية؟
في السعودية مشروع مشترك أكثر من استحواذات
بس المستقبل واعد بصراحة
تعرف في استحواذات ناجحة
واستحواذات للأسف ما مشيت تمام بالعالم وعندنا في الـ...
أعتقد أكثر الاستحواذات أهم شيء فيها اللي هو موضوع الاندماج
اليوم أنا عقليتي «بي دبليو سي»
أنت عقليتك ثمانية أو جاي من شركة معينة
كيف أجي؟
تناسب الثقافة
تناسب الثقافة وكيف أنا، فهذه من ناحية
فاحنا دائمًا أنا أحكي لك «بي دبليو سي» فاتحين عينينا
على أنت لما بدك تستثمر
تبغى تستثمر في شيء أنت تحتاجه ومش موجود عندك
فدائمًا بنعمل مسح ضوئي احنا أنه أيش الخبرات الموجودة وأيش...
وفي كثير شركات، ما شاء الله، محلية
الشركات المحلية الآن صار في جمعية
عشان أتذكر اسمها الجمعية، الجمعية للمستشارين السعوديين
واحنا جزء من هذه الجمعية هذه الجمعية
هذه الجمعية فيها أكثر الشركات اللي حكيتلك عنها
زي «كي بي أم جي» و«بي دابلو سي» و«إي واي»
ومجموعة شركات محلية كيف ننمي هذه المهنة
ونطورها في المستقبل، ونستثمر فيها
في «دي دبليو سي» نحن نتعاون مع الشركات المحلية
يعني عندك عدّة شركات نتمنى أنها تتطور أكثر من ناحية الاستراتيجية
لأن أكثرها مركز أعتقد على التنفيذ والتكنولوجيا
ولكن نتعامل كثير معهم، وبعضهم على فكرة
من الاستشاريين اللي خرجوا من هذه الشركات وبنوا
أنا من زمان كنت أفكر ليش ما أطلع، وأسوّي شركتي
هؤلاء من اللي الله أعطاهم الشجاعة
وبالعكس احنا ندعمهم على فكرة
كيف تدعمهم، تشتغلون معهم كاستشاريين؟
لا تدريب، وبعض الأحيان استشارات
بعض الأحيان يكون عندهم امكانيات قويَّة في مناطق معينة
ويكونوا جزء من المشروع
وبعض الأحيان هم ينادوا لنا على المشاريع اللي معهم
بنحب نشوف أكثر من هذه المواضيع، وإن شاء الله
بحكم خبرتك، أيش نصيحتك لقادة هذه الشركات الاسشارية؟
وأيش المفترض يركزون عليه
في ظل أنه تقريبًا 80 أو 90% من السوق
هو رايح للستة أسماء اللي ذكرناهم قبل شوي؟
فالحصة حقتهم ضئيلة جدًّا، وهذا المشهد قد لا يكون مستمر
أيش أهم الممارسات اللي يفترض يفكرون فيها حتى يزيدوا حصتهم؟
أيش نقاط القوة المفترض يبنوها؟
أيش نقاط الضعف اللي يفترض أن يتلافونها؟
أيش توجيهك لهم؟
أول شيء، أنا راح أقول عن الشركات الستة اللي أنا ذكرتهم
بالذَّات الشركات الأربعة الكبار
أنا بنظري، عندنا احنا في المجتمع هنا
ما ننظر لهم أنه هذول شركات خارجية
هذول شركات منا، وفينا زي ما بحكوا
لما تكون شركة لها 100 سنة في السعودية، وأكثر موظفينها 60% سعوديين
هذول من المجتمع
بس أنا عشان أغطي لك هذا النقطة
لازم أنه احنا كمان ننظر لهذه الشركات
أنه ما هي شركات عمليات أو جاي تأخذ مشاريع وتروح
فهذه نقطة مهمة لشبابنا اللي في المجتمع، هذه موجودة للمستقبل
ولازم نستخدمها ونتعلم منها حتى لو بنسوي الشركات
الشركات المحلية أنا بحس أنه شغالة بجدية على تطوير نفسها
برأيي الشديد أن أنت اليوم كشركة محلية
ما راح تقدر بالذات في بداية الأمور
أن يكون عندك كل الخبرات اللي في العالم
فاليوم لازم أعمل أنا شراكات
اليوم، أنا لو أنا عندي شركتي الخاصة استشارية
وأنت فجأة جيتني قلت لي: والله أنا أبغى خبراء في الصحة يسوّو لي كذا
فلازم يكون عندي أنا شبكة خبراء في العالم
سواءً محلية أو في العالم
شبكة بين بعض اللي يتعاونوا مع بعض
هذه نقطة مهمة
وما يكون عندنا الغرور أني أقول لا والله أنا أقدر أسوي كل شيء
ما فيه إنسان يقدر يسوي كل شيء
لازم نأخذ الخبرات إذا بتفيد العميل
الشيء الثاني أعتقد الاستثمار أكثر
يعني الاستثمار أكثر في في تطوير الحلول
اليوم احنا...
شوف أنا «بي دبليو سي» شوف أيش في خبرات هنا وهنا
في «بي دبليو سي» وأيش صار، وأيش عُمل
ونشوف كيف هذه راح تفيدنا عنَّا في السوق السعودي
أو في سوق الشرق الأوسط
لما أكون شركة محلية ما عندي هذا الوصول
فلازم أستثمر في البحوثات هذه
حتى لو هي شركات من الطرف الثالث زي ما يسموها
بس لازم أستثمر أكثر
ما أضل ماشي على أيش ما قدامي أشتغل عليه
لازم أستثمر أشوف شو المستقبل بيكون
وأخذ رأي العملاء في هذا الموضوع
بس في عدة شركات على مقاس كبير
احنا نقول شركات محلية كأنها شركات صغيرة
في شركات ضخمة في السعودية بهذا الاتجاه
زي «عِلم» وزي «الثقة» وزي غيرها
برضو من المآخذ على شركات الاستشارات
هو موضوع أنها تسمع العميل اللي يبغي يسمعه
فعشان أضمن العقد، وعشان يتجدد العقد
وعشان يمشي الاتفاق أيش تبغاني أقول لك حاضر راح أقول لك
ويضرب مثال «الدكتور حزام السبيعي»
ذكر مثال في تويتر عن قصة فشل ذريع، وسريع لمشروع «سي أن أن بلس»
لخدمة البث المباشر بعد أربع أسابيع من إطلاقها
وهو يعزو الفشل إلى الأرقام المضخمة من شركة «ماكنزي»
اللي كانت مستشار للمشروع
وتوقعت أرقام مشركات معينة في السنة الأولى
وافترضت أن «سي أن أن بلس» عندها هذه العلامة التجارية
القادرة على جلب المشركين بشكل معين
فهذا مجرد مثال على حالات كثيرة
قدمت الشركات الاستشارية توقعات
ترضي العميل وتسعده لكنها تخليه يصدم في الجدار بعدين
أيش تعليقك على هذا الموضوع؟
طبعًا أنا هذه الحالة ما بعرف عنها
يعني بالضبط أيش اللي صار فيها
هي مجرد مثال لعملية المبالغة في الأرقام
طبعًا هي بتعتمد كلها على المعطيات
بعض الأحيان أنت بتقدم المعطيات الموجودة
وعشان أكون صريح معك بعض العملاء لا يحبوا الواقع
إي، شلون تتعامل مع هذول؟
عشان ما تخسر الصفقة وتؤدّي واجبك؟
هي أصلًا...
عشان بس أكون حريص
عادةً هذا الموضوع بيصير بعد الصفقة
بس عشان نكون...
هو يسوي الدراسة اليوم خلص وبيأخذ المشروع فهي...
عشان كذا أنا ما أقدر أجاوب
لأنه ما أدري أيش صار على الجانب الثاني
هل التوقعات أو المفترضات اللي كانت مأخوذة غلط؟
هل العميل أعطاهم مفترضات غلط؟
النية أعتقد لهذه الشركات بدون أسماء لشركات
أنه أنا لازم أسوي شغل ممتاز
سمعتي كشخص، وسمعتي كشركة وعلامتي التجاريّة
يعني أنا آجي وأخذ معاك المشروع
وأحكي لك اللي عاجبك عشان أخذ المشروع
وأضيّع سمعتي في السوق اللي أخسر المشاريع الثانية؟
صعبة
الآن فلما تيجي لتنفيذ المشروع
انسى موضوع أنه أنا بقول لك اللي تبغى عشان أخذ المشروع
هذه احنا خلصنا هذا الموضوع الآن أنا داخل في المشروع
في معلومات بعض الأحيان تطلبها الشركات الاستشارية من العميل
يمكن تكون المعلومات أو المفترضات غلط
زي ما قلت لك
مش كل الدكاترة عملياتهم ناجحة
فاحنا دائمًا ننسى الـ 99% الدراسات الناجحة
ونركز على 1% اللي ما نجحت، وهذول الاستشاريين...
فأنا برأيي أنه الاستشاري لما يقدم رأي
وأنا حُطّت في هذه المواقف في الزمانات
والعميل هذا غلط وهذا كذا...
لازم أنه أيش الآثار الجانبية لو احنا قدمناها بالطريقة...
هذا المقترح
بالأخير القرار للعميل
أنا بعطيك الخيار الأول هذه مخاطره، وهذه حسناته
أنا بناءً على المعطيات الموجودة بقول هذا الاختيار الثاني هو الصحيح
وبناءً على الخبرات اللي شفناها
إذا العميل اختار خيار ثاني وعارف...
فدائمًا احنا بكل حاجة ما هي بس على السجل
نختار الحالة من 1000 حالة
يعني الحالة الوحدة من 1000، ويصير التركيز عليها
ويصير أنه هذه هي سبب الـ...
وهذول هم المشكلة، هم الاستشاريين المشكلة
بس أنت لا تنسى الـ 999 حالة الثانية استفاد منها العميل
بس في مقولة، جودة المستشار من جودة عميله
طبعًا
بمعنى أنه قد ما يطلب منك العميل راح يطلِّع أفضل ما عندك
فبالنسبة لك أرخص شيء، وأربح شيء
أنك تعطيه شيء يغطي المطلوب
لا
إلى أن يتحداك، ويضغط عليك، ويرفض العمل مرة واثنين
ثم أنت تجيب أحد أكثر خبرة، هل هذا السيناريو دائمًا يصير؟
لا، شوف خليني...
إذا هذه صارت في حالة أو حالات من بعض الشركات
أنا بحكي لك بشكل عام، وبالذَّات من طرفنا احنا
بالعكس بنقول نبغى نروح فوق التوقعات
حتى لما نجي نسوي مراجعة من العميل هل احنا حققنا التوقعات؟
ومشينا معك على توقعاتك، ولا تعدينا التوقعات؟
فأنا اللي بحكيه اليوم
جودة الاستشاري من جودة العميل معناها
مش أنه العميل قاعد يطالب فيك ويعمل
العميل عارف أيش يبغى
أيش الغرض من هذا المشروع؟
أيش المطلوب من هذا المشروع؟
يصنع القرار بسرعة
العميل يعطيك المعلومات المطلوبة
فإذا أنت توجهك ما هو واضح
ولا عندك المعلومات اللي تعطيني إياها عشان أنفذ
وما بتأخذ القرار بسرعة، أنا ضعفت كاستشاري
هذه ما هي أن والله أنه أنا أقدر أسحب وأعمل...
أعتقد هذه أنت ما بتحكي على شركات ما هي معروفة في العالم
طريقة استخدام الاستشارة اللي بيطلبه
وورشات العمل اللي بتصير تُعطى المعلومات ونقرر
مش أنه أنا...
بس أنه هل يكون الهدف أنه أنا أشوف أقل شيء أعطيك إياه؟
طيب ما أنا راح أضر حالي
أنا أقول لك هذه القصة الصغيرة
أنا متذكر في مشروع من أيام عام 2000
الخدمات المصرفية عبر الإنترنت
لما كانت في وقت الإنترنت ما كان عنا في الشرق الأوسط وفي العالم
وأنا كنت شغال على هذا المشروع كمدير مشروع في أحد البنوك
وهذه كانت في السعودية طبعًا
وهذه كانت تحدي بين البنوك من يطلع الأول
فكان فيه ضغط على توقيت إطلاق الخدمات المصرفية عبر الإنترنت
أنتم الجيل عشتوا فيها مأخوذة
تحصيل حاصل
شغالين أربعة وعشرين ساعة، مذبوح أنا
ومواعيد التسليم للعميل كانت بصراحة ما هي بسيطة
بعدين جاءنا شريك من...
إذا أنا أتذكر من إيطاليا
كبير يسوي مراجعة الجودة
يدير الجودة، ويشوف الجودة مع العميل
فأنا توقعته لما يجي يسأل العميل كيف الموقع بيكون
كيف سوُّو الشباب الشغل، وكيف...
تدري أيش سأله؟
وبحكي لك إياها بالإنقليزي وبحاول أترجمها
قال له: هل نجعلك تبدو جيدًا؟
هل احنا خليناك...
طبعًا هذا المسؤول على الخدمات المصرفية عبر الإنترنت
لتبدو جيدًا قدام إدارتك أنه احنا نفذنا؟
وأنا قاعد...
هذا الكلام قبل ثلاثة وعشرين سنة
يا ابن الحلال قاعدين نشتغل ليل ونهار
احنا على الخدمات المصرفية عبر الإنترنت وذُبحنا
وضلُّوا يغيروا المتطلبات
وجاي تقول له: هل تبدو جيدًا؟
بس ضلت لليوم هذا في رأسي
أنه واحدة من الأهداف
أنه أنا أبغاك تُشع من هذا الشيء
يعني أنك أنت تنجح نجاحك من نجاحي
فأتوقع 99.99% من الشركات الاستشارية
اللي شغالة اليوم، وأنا بشوفها في السوق عندها نفس الهدف
أنه نجاحك، ونجاح الرؤية ونجاح تنفيذ المشروع
احنا جزء منها
فهذه اللي أنا بقول لك يعني...
وبالحديث عن نجاح الرؤية أنتم صدر لكم تقرير جميل
قبل أسابيع قليلة اللي هو النشرة الاقتصادية
ومتزامنة مع منتصف الرحلة، منتصف رحلتنا لـ 2030
أنا قرأت التقرير، أعجبني فيه أنكم كنتوا إلى حد ما موضوعيين
أنا أعرف أنكم ما تبغوا تزعلوا عملاءكم
لكن أشرتوا إلى بعض الأشياء المتأخرة
مثلًا موضوع الاستثمار الأجنب المباشر
موضوع، اللي أنتم سميتموه السياحة الدينية
احنا نسميه خدمة ضيوف الرحمن
هذه أنتم تكلمتوا عنها بأنها فيها تباطؤ، وما هي نفس المستهدفات
ودِّي لو تمر على هذا التقرير، وتعطينا من زاوية نظرك كمختص
وكخبير وشريك في هذه الرحلة من بدايتها
أيش أهم ما تحقق في النصف الأول؟
وأيش أهم الدروس المستفادة اللي نتمنى نتلافاها في النصف الثاني؟
سؤال ممتاز، طبعًا الرؤية موضوع لحاله كبير جدًّا
احنا أخذنا في هذه الدراسة، زي ما أنت حكيت أهداف أن وين احنا؟
الهدف منها أنه زي أنت في الطريق للدمام
بنصف الطريق تبغى تعرف أنا وصلت
هل أنا فعلًا بنص الطريق وللا لا؟
فأخذنا الأربعة عشر عامود، وأهداف في الرؤية
ومشينا عليهم أنه أيش كان الهدف الرئيسي لهذه الأهداف؟
ووين احنا من موقع لهذه الأهداف؟
وجدنا أنه مجموعة كبيرة فيها تعديناها
أو قريبين جدًّا في نص الطريق، وقريبين جدًّا من الوصول لها
كمثال تفعيل عمل المرأة
عمل المرأة إذا أنا أتذكر كان التصور لـ 2030 أن نوصل 32 أو 30%
30%
30% بعام 2030
اليوم احنا أول كوارتر 36%
وهذه أنا شايفها قدامي في السوق، وفي «بي دبليو سي» نفسها
أنتم 25% موظفيكم...
نساء
25% موظفيكم سعوديات، و33% أتوقع نساء
احنا 33% نساء مزبوط
فالـ 56% السعوديين ككل
فاحنا نبغى نلحق على الرؤية من ناحية النساء في «بي دبليو سي»
لمَّا تيجي على السكن
موضوع السكن نفس الشيء
الرؤية حاطَّة 70% تملك المواطنين
واحنا اليوم على 67%
الإيرادات الغير نفطية
طبعًا هذه يمكن أكبر النجاحات الإيرادات الغير نفطية
تعديها ووين راح توصل
الآن نجي للمناطق اللي...
خلينا نقول يمكن تحتاج انتباه أكثر وهي أصعب
بصراحة جلب الاستثمار الأجنبي يعتمد كثير على البنية التحتية
إذا بتنظر للموضوع اللي ذكرناه في أول البرنامج
اللي هو على شركات الجهات الإقليمية
المراكز الإقليمية للشركات في الرياض
هذه جزء من جلب الاستثمارات
ويكونوا الرؤساء، وصناع القرار قاعدين في الرياض
وهذه حتى راح تصير استثمارات أكبر
أتوقع فيه اعتماديات بينهم
يعني اليوم أنا عشان أجيب الشركات
في قوانين لازم تتغير بسرعة سواءً القوانين الضربية
تدخيل مثلًا مدارس أكثر
أنا بلاحظها هذه أكثر الخبراء اللي بنحاول نجيبهم
أول شيء يدور عليه يقول لك وين المدارس؟
هل في مدارس كفاية وللَّا لا؟
وأنا أتعامل كثير مع وزارة الاستثمار
وفيه إجراءات، ومشاريع ضخمة بهذا الموضوع أنه جلب...
فإذا تنظر بشكل عام، احنا سابقين الـ...
فأنت قلت الاستثمار الأجنبي فيه تباطؤ
ضيوف الرحمن أو السياحة الدينية
ضيوف الرحمن كان في نقاش فيها
عشان ضيوف الرحمن
أنت لا تنسي أن احنا مرينا بجائحة كورونا
فالأهداف اللي كانت...
لما حُطت الأهداف هذه ما كانت جائحة كورونا في الأفق
ففي تأخير بتحقيق الأهداف لضيوف الرحمن
خدمة الضيوف الرحمن، وأنه يرتفع عدد الضيوف الرحمن
ولكن هذا، بإذن الله، راح تلحق في السنوات الجاية
بإذن الله، قبل 2030
أيضًا لفت نظري تعليق من جهتكم على موضوع الضرائب
كنت تقولون أن...
أظهرت الميزانيات المشهورة حتى الآن
جانبًا إيجابيًّا على المستوى المالي
وهو عدم وجود تقلبات في السياسة الضريبية
أو حتى بعض التدابير الجديدة المهمة
وهو أمر غير مسبوق خلال فترة الإزدهار النفطي
فقد حافظت السعودية على معدل ضريبة القيمة المضافة البالغة 15%
أنتم اعتبرتوا الحفاظ على 15% شيء إيجابي
بينما كثير من المجتمع يشوفونه شيء سلبي
أو شيء يضغط على قدرتهم الشرائية
ليش تعتبرونه إيجابي؟
القيمة المضافة اليوم إذا نزل سعر البترول
لا تحتاج الدولة لرفع القيمة
هذا هو الهدف اللي احنا نحكي عنه كشيء إيجابي
لأنه ممكن أنت بأسهل طريقة في الدول الغربية
أنه إذا نزل الدخل بجهة معينة، أرفع الضرائب
عشان أعوض هذا الدخل من المواطنين والأمور هذه
احنا بنقول أنه هذا الموضوع جيد أنها ما تغيرت
مع التحدي بأسعار البترول في الفترة الماضية
أنه مو قاعدين نرفع القيمة المضافة
فأنتم بالنسبة لكم الجزء الإيجابي هو حالة الاستقرار
بغض النظر عن مستوياتها
طبعًا للمواطن في المستقبل
أكيد المواطن يفضل أناها تنزل، وبإذن الله، يعني...
في من الأشياء أيضًا اللي كانت لفتت نظري في التقرير
هي جزئية المقارنة مع دول الخليج في التعافي ما بعد الجائحة
أنتم قلتوا نمو الناتج المحلي راح يكون متواضع هذه السنة
ولكنا أعلى 14% من مرحلة ما قبل كورونا
بينما دول خليج ما هي محققة هذا النمو
يا دوب جايبة أرقام عام 2019
بلغة مبسطة أنتم قاعدين تقولوا:
أغلب دول الخليج عادت لنفس النقطة اللي كانت في 2019
السعودية تجاوزت هذه النقطة
أيش الجانب اللي ينسب له الفضل في هذا النمو؟
أيش الشيء اللي صار في السعودية ما صار في دول الخليج؟
أتوقع، وهذه لازم اتأكد منها، اللي صار في السعودية أن السياحة
كمية السياحة اللي صارت في السعودية
مقارنةً بدول الخليج اللي زي الإمارات...
السياحة متوفرة عندها إذا كنت راح تقارنها من قبل
هذا شيء إضافي
السياحة الداخلية في السعودية زادت بشكل كبير بعد الجائحة
يمكن هي جزء من السياحة الداخلية زي موسم الرياض، وجدة
بس هذا الموضوع أنا إذا تحب أرجع لك فيه
لأنه تفاصيله بالضبط لازم أرجع للمستشار الاقتصادي
ممكن مو شرط، أبو بدر، نحتاج بالضبط من وين جاء هذا الرقم
بس بشكل عام ما الإصلاحات التي قامت بها السعودية
بشكل أسرع، وأكثر عمقًا من بقية الدول الخليج؟
حتى يبان عندنا أثر إيجابي أكثر من بقية منطقة
رغم أنك أنت الأكبر، والأثقل في الحركة
فيفترض أنك أنت تكون أبطأهم في الحركة
شوف أنا بخلال الجائحة، واحدة من الحاجات اللي شفتها
كانت بصراحة يمكن هذه...
طبعًا أنا ما أعرف أيش دول الخليج الثانية سوَّت
ولكن كانت شيء مؤثر معي أنا شخصيًًا
أن الدولة في الفترة كانت تراقب جميع القطاعات بمؤشرات خلال الجائحة
وكانوا يطلعوا بقرارات كيف تدعم هذا القطاع خلال الجائحة
فأنت ما كان فيه انتظار لبعد الجائحة
يعني في وقت من الأوقات كان بيع بالتجزئة متأثر
لأنه الناس كانت قاعدة في البيوت
فكان أيش الدعم للقوانين والسياسات
اللي الدولة تحتاج تساعدها تدعم هذا القطاع
قطاعات أخرى كانت زي عندك لوحة القيادة
اللي قاعدين يرقبوا فيها القطاعات
ويطلعوا في القرارات اللي تدعم هذا القطاع
أعتقد أن إدارة الأزمة بالطريقة هذه
هي اللي ساعدت القطاعات، والحكومة تتعافى بشكل أسرع
وكان في مجموعات أو لجان من جميع الجهات اللي بسرعة تتخذ القرار
على أساس أن...
سواءً لدعم قطاع معين أو تسهيل لقطاع معين وهكذا
هذه توقعاتي ولكن ممكن نرجع للاقتصاديين بالضبط نعرف...
وزي ما تفضلت أنت يمكن حتى من جهات دولية
صدر تقييم للسعودية بأنها ثاني أفضل دولة في المجموعة العشرين
في التعافي ما بعد الجائحة
وهذه من أهم مكتسبات الحكومة الفاعلة
اللي اليوم قادرة تتحرك بشكل سريع تستجيب، وبمرونة عالية للمتغيرات
وكمان واحدة من النقاط أن السعودية اليوم جزء من الـ«جي 20»
أسرع اقتصاد نمو في العالم تقريبًا
في العام الماضي، السنة هذه بتوقع أنه...
السنة هذه ممكن أكون شوي...
عشان أسعار النفط
أبو بدر ودّي أختم بمجموعة من أسئلة الأصدقاء
جاءنا 250 سؤال، مستوعب؟
يا ساتر
إي والله
وكثير منها عن موضوع الموارد البشرية فنبدأ فيه
طبعًا أي سؤال يتكلم عن القطاع احنا تجنبناه
عشان ما نحطك في حرج
الأسئلة كلها عن «بي دبليو سي» تحديدًا
ناس موظفين فيها، وناس غادروها
وناس ما يزالون يعملوا فيها
ففي واحد يقول أنا مسؤول في استقطاب المواهب
فُصلت من عملي لأني رشحت شريك
وأنجز كل المقابلات، ستة مقابلات
بعدين لما عُرف أنه سعودي رفضوا الترشيح
واعتبروا أني أنا مقصر لأني ما أوضحت هذا الجانب
فكان فيها صراحةً الرسالة، إن صحَّت
فهي عنصرية جدًّا مقيتة راح تكون مزعجة
وأسئلة كثيرة تتكلم على موضوع عدد الشركاء
أنت أكدت أنه حدود 15%
لا أتوقع ولا أتمنى أن يكونون 100% سعوديين
لأننا محتاجين لخبرات من كل العالم، بس توقعت 50%
وبشرح لك أنا بعدين التحدي على هذا الموضوع
يا ريت، موضوع الشركاء وترشيحهم في السعودية
هل أن تكون سعودي نقطة ضعف عشان توصل للشركاء؟
ولا أيش نظرتكم لها؟
تبغاني أرد على النقطة الأولى ولا هذا؟
يا ريت على النقطة الأولى، والموضوع بشكل العام
طبعًا احنا في شركة «بي دبليو سي»
عندنا شيء بنسميه الخط الساخن للأخلاقيات
وهذا عالمي
فأن شخص يجي يذكر شيء من هذا القبيل
لو فيه عنا مشكلة زي هذه كان راحت للخط الساخن للأخلاقيات
ويدخل فيها تحقيق
فهذه الشركة...
ممكن أنا ما أعرف
أنا خايف يكون موظف زعلان
بس أنه تكون فيه عنصرية أنه واحد ترشح
ووصل، وبعدين هو فُصل عشان هذا، هذه مستحيلة
مستحيلة
مستحيلة، عندنا 1200 موظف سعودي
وفيه الخطوات اللازمة أنه نحقق في هذا الموضوع إذا صار شيء
يعني اليوم أي واحد ممكن يرفع هذه الشكوى عالميًّا
هذه ما هي مزحة
ويحط لها، ولازم نعمل لها تقارير لازمة أيش اللي صار
وكيف التحقيق ونتائج التحقيق؟
فأنا راح أتجنب هذه لأنه ما عندي المثل اللي أرد عليه
السؤال الثاني كان على الشركاء صح؟
صحيح، ليش عدد الشركاء السعوديين قليل؟
أولًا، خلينا نبدأ، أنا ذكرت لك أخوي عمر
أنه مجال الاستشارات ما كان مرغوب
قبل خلينا نقول 2015 للشباب الخليجيين بشكل عام على فكرة
يمكن السعوديين الآن أكثر مواطنين اللي...
تقريبًا تكاد تكون هي أول خيار
الخيار المفضل لأغلب الخريجين المتميزين حاليًا
الآن، ولكن لو رجعت قبل 2015-2016
خليني أقول لك أنا أشتغل إثنا عشر ساعة
في مجالات أخرى
كأعداد وكخبرة في مجال الاستشارات أنا أقول ما هو التدقيق والأخرى
ما عندك الإمداد
ما عندك حجم الخبرات المتوفرة في هذا الموضوع
لأنهم دخلوا متأخرًا لهذا القطاع
دخلوا متأخرين
فاحنا جينا من سنين قلنا احنا كشركة
بنوظف في السعودية تقريبًا 200 خريج جديد كل سنة
نبغى يكون 99% سعوديين
وكنَا ناجحين في هذا الموضوع
ليش؟ عشان نوصل للـ...
أيش يصير؟
الشباب طبعًا الطلب عالي عليهم هذه الخبرات
وخاصة لما يكون عنده سنتين خبرة في شركة زي «بي دبليو سي»
والطلب عليه مش بس في من الشركات الاستشارية الثانية
من الجهات الحكومية، من هذا...
لأنه هذا اللي تحتاجه البلد، الخبرات هذه
فهذول أنه يضل، ويكمل المشوار عشان يوصل شريك
ما هي سهلة
يجي له عروض، وإغراءات ومجالات ممتازة، ما هي مجالات سيئة
فاحنا طلعنا في برنامج في «بي دبليو سي» سميناه «همم»
وهذا البرنامج بالإنقليزي احنا بنقول عنه
استقطاب، وتطوير، واحتفاظ للسعوديين
بصراحة هو «همم» برنامج
اللي هو استقطاب وتطوير والحفاظ على الموظف
ليش طلعنا في هذا البرنامج؟
لأنه أنا شخصيًّا أبغى أشوف أكثر شُركاء
أفضل لشركة زي «بي دبليو سي»
أن يكون خليني أقول 50% من الشركاء اللي عندي...
هذا المنطقي
فهمت علي؟ فاهم السوق، ومتدرب باسم الشركة
خلاص أنت قربت للعميل، ويخدم المجتمع بنفس الوقت
فأقول لك بعدما يخلص السنتين يُجذب من الشركات
والآن إذا بتلاحظ...
وطبعًا أنا لما أجلس مع بعض العملاء الكبار عندنا في البلد
فيقول لي نفس الأسئلة هذه، وأشرح له أنا الموضوع هذا
وأنا متذكر عميل أقول لك إياها صراحة في أحد الجهات
قال لي: يا رياض أنت تقول أنه أنتم 50% سعوديين
وين هم؟
قلت له تعرف أنه أنت أخذت من عندي خمسة عشر موظف سعودي؟
فقال لي طيب هذه واجب عليكم، قلت: أكيد احنا هذا...
تروح الآن لكثير من العملاء تلاقي كثير من «بي دبليو سي»
وأكيد من الشركات الاستشارية الثانية
لأنهم يعتبرونكم مُرشّح جيد
أنتم تعبتوا في البحث، والتدريب فيأخذهم جاهزين منكم
واحنا فخورين في هذه الشباب
وبالعكس أنا مصلحتي أن هذا الشاب ينجح وين ما هو
فقلت له: بس خلِّينا شوي، الله يطول عمرك
عشان هذه الشباب توصل مرحلة الشراكة
فالأعداد المتسلسلة هذه قاعدة تكبر اللي في الإدارة الوسطى الآن
وقاعدة تطلع للمجالات الأخرى
إذا بتطلع في «بي دبليو سي»
في التدقيق لأنه هذه المهنة قديمة شوي
راح تلاقي فيها أعداد سعوديين كثير
هذه بالشركاء؟
في الشركاء، نعم
إذا بتروح للضرائب
لأنه هذه المهنة متوفرة وموجودة هتلاقي فيها أعداد كبار
أتمنى أنه قريبًا نشوف أكثر وأكثر
احنا عندنا سعوديين في الاستشارات شركاء
ومن أنجح الشركاء بصراحة
كم متوسط السنوات اللي أحتاجها
عشان أنتقل من شخص جديد توني متخرج ومتوظف عندكم
إلى أن أكون شريك، كم متوسط سنوات الخبرة؟
بين اللي كله جايب رقم واحد في كل المستويات
بدِّي أقول: بين عشر سنين واثنا عشر سنة
فهذه الفترة اللي يحتاجها
هذه عشان يوصل شريك، بس إذا يقدر يصبر
من الإغراءات في خلال المجال
لأنه شوف بعد فترة لما يصير مدير مرشد
في الإدارة العليا، ومدير...
هذه الشركات ليش ما تدفع زي الجهات الحكومية؟
لأنه يعتبر، في كم السنة الأولى
هذه استثمار مني كشركة فيك
أنا قاعد الآن أصرف بلاوي على التدريب والتتبع
بعدها أنا راح أصير كشركة أستفيد من خبراتك
لأن أنت راح تصير المستشار للعملاء
فصرت أقدر أعطيك أكثر
فكلما عَلا أكثر كلما بعطيه أكثر
احنا شبابنا وجيلنا مستعجل
قديمًا الشركات هذه ما كانت ترضى تعين مستشارين
بمستويات أو بعدد سنوات أعلى من خريج جامعة
احنا فتحنا الباب الآن عشان نجيب شباب أكثر
بمستويات مدير ومدير أول عشان أقدر أدخلهم
هذه الشيء الوحيد اللي ما هو سهل فيها
أنه الآن مرت عليه ستة أو سبعة سنوات
خلينا نقول في مجال شركة معينة
بس ما هو استشاري
فالآن أنت لازم تستثمر كيف أنا أقلبه
وأدربه أنه يصير استشاري، ويفيد العملاء في هذه الطريقة
هل صحيح 90% الخروج سنويًّا للسعوديين؟
لا، وين؟
اللي ما يكمل سنة
لا، ما هي 90%
أنا ما أعتقد أنها تقرب إلى هذا الرقم نهائيًّا
حسنًا
بس هي أنت لاحظ يعني اليوم العدد عالي بس ما هو 90%
أحكي لك أتوقع في العشرينات
كان في الثلاثينات قبل كم من سنة
واحنا بعدما حطينا برنامج «همم»
نزل للعشرينات أتوقع
يمكن من الملاحظات على بيئة العمل هو موضوع
اختلاف الجو بحسب الشريك اللي أنت تحته
يعني ما فيه ثقافة موحد
مثلًا إذا أنت تحت فلان هذا إنسان خلوق، ومتسامح وداعم
هذه شكلها من الموظفين
أي حتى هو ذكر أسماء، لكن ما راح أقول أسماء
لكن يقول الشريك فلان الناس تنبسط تشتغل معه
وحتى طريقة استقطابه لأشخاص أصحاب قيم
ومستويات معينة، ومبادئ
الشريك فلان لا، حاد وصعب جدًّا ما يتحمله إلا اللي مثله
أو الأشخاص الانتهازين، اضرب وأهرب
فهذول كلهم «بي دبليو سي» شلون أقدر...؟
يعني كيف لها أكثر من وجه؟
ما فيه سياسات موحدة؟
ثقافة موحَّدة يظهر على كل الأقسام؟
السياسة واحدة، المخلوقات مختلفة
ولكن احنا ما بنتركها للشخص، عشان أكون صريح معك
أنت اليوم في حاجات في الدي إن إيه
يعني أنت بتدرب هذه العملية، وهذه السياسات
وهذه المحفزات وهذه الـ...
فاحنا من عدة سنوات أدخلنا طريقة نسمع من موظفيننا في المشاريع
اليوم احنا شيء بنسميه فحص صحة المشروع
بحاول أترجم لك إياها
تشييك على صحة المشروع
وهذه الموظف من الصغير
لكن كل مشروع يدخل الموظف، وهذه ما يعرف عنها الشريك، مين الشخص
ويدخل بقول والله أنا عندي واحد وعندي اثنين
الأمور طيبة هنا، الأمور كذا
الشريك موجود أو مش موجود وكذا يعطينا
وهذه عادةً بنطلع عليها كل أسبوعين
بنشوف هذه عندنا هنا في أحمر
أرسل عليها التشييك، وشوف الشباب أيش القصة؟
طبعًا أنت قاعد تحط سيطرة
احنا بنحاول الوقاية خير من العلاج
بنحاول أن نقيم هذول الشركاء أو هذول المدراء
بطريقة التعامل فيه يجي لهم...
آخر السنة يجي له، احنا نسميه ردود الفعل التصاعدية
أيش يعني ردود الفعل التصاعدية؟
ردود الفعل التصاعدية...
من الأسفل إلى الأعلى
أيش الشباب بيقولوا عن هذا الشخص؟
وهذا يدخل في تقييمه، وفيه أقران من نفس الطبق
فأنت عاملها من 360 درجة
إلا يطلع لك طبعًا شخص...
يعني هذه الأخلاقيات أنت عارف هذه بالدي أن إيه
المهم أنه نراقب هذا الموضوع
نشوف التغذية الراجعة تبع الشباب
ونأخذ فعل معين نحلها بسرعة
في أسئلة كثيرة على موضوع مستقبل هذه الصناعة
صناعة الاستشارات، وصناعة التدقيق مع الذكاء الاصطناعي
أنت يمكن شفت «شات جي بي تي»
كثير جربوا يطلبوا استراتيجية لقطاع كذا في دولة كذا
وإكتشفوا أنه أعطاهم تقريبًا استراتيجية
وفيها معايير، أنتم جزء كبير من قيمتكم المضافة
هي البيانات اللي عندكم كمقارنات معيارية مع العالم
إذا الذكاء الاصطناعي أو الـ«إيه آي» بيعطيني كل هذا
أيش موقعكم في المستقبل؟
على فكرة، هذا سؤال ممتاز جدًّا
طبعًا هذا الموضوع ليس فقط لقطاع الاستشارات
هذا الموضوع، الدكتور راح يحتاج أنه أيش بيأثر على قطاعه
الـ«إيه آي» أو الذكاء الاصطناعي
اليوم احنا بدراسات طبعًا بدراساتنا، ومناقشاتنا داخل الشركة
احنا نبغى نستفيد زي أي قطاع ثاني من الذكاء الاصطناعي
كيف يقوّي المستشار؟
اليوم الحاجات اللي أنت قلتها مثلًا
اللي ما أنت شايف منها قيمة
هذا خلي الذكاء الاصطناعي يسويه
وأنا أصير أركز معك على الحاجات المهمة أكثر
فاحنا قاعدين نراجع جميع الخدمات اللي عندنا
ونشوف كيف الذكاء الاصطناعي
راح يصير المستشار عن عشرة
أنا راح أقدر أخدمك، بإذن الله، إذا قدرنا
أخدم العميل بتكلفة أقل، وقيمة أعلى
وهذه أنا بقول تُطبق على جميع القطاعات
أعطيك مثال كنت أحكي مع شبابنا
أنه كيف أخلي عن طريق الـ«إيه آي» مدير المشروع الواحد
ما يعادل خمسة أو عشرة من مدير المشاريع قبل الـ«إيه آي»
يساعده، وكل الشغلات اللي تضيع وقته
بالادارة أو الحاجات اللي ما لها قيمة
كيف أخلي الـ«إيه آي» يسوِّي له إياها
ويصير هو مركز على تنفيذ المشروع
وعلى دراسة المخاطر، أيش أسوِّي بهذه المخاطر؟
فأنا أتوقع أن الـ«إيه آي» الاستشارات ما راح تنتهي
التدقيق ما راح ينتهي
لأنه كلما تطور المجال، كلَّما اختلفت الاحتياجات
ولكن التوقعات من المستشار أو الشخص راح تكون أعلى
فاحنا نبغى نهيئ كيف أخلِّي هذا الشخص يركز على القيمة
أي شيء ما له دخل تشيله منه
فأنا بالعكس شايفها إيجابية ما نخاف من هذا الموضوع
وإنما هي ممكّن لكم
ممكّن، بالضبط
أبو بدر ودّي أختم بهذا السؤال
ويمكن نادر الأشخاص عدد الأشخاص
اللي أقدر أسألهم هذا السؤال تحديدًا رح يكونوا محدودين
لكن أنت واحد منهم اللي يقدر أقول له
أيش أهم مكتسبات الرؤية
اللي عموم الناس ما يقدروا يشوفوها؟
أنتم تدخلون داخل الجهات الحكومية
أنتم تتعاملون مع صناع القرار
أنتم تشتغلون على المشاريع قبلما تظهر
أنتم اشتغلتوا قبل الرؤية، وبعد الرؤية
طبعًا أنا ما أبحث عن مديح عام أنا أتكلم عن وصف موضوعي
ما هي أهم المكتسبات اللي اليوم في السعودية اكتسبناها
وحققناها وهي داخل القطاع الحكومي
لا يستطيع العامي أن يراها
لأن في أشياء كثيرة واضحة، والناس تلامسها
بس أبغى شيء أنتم من الداخل
تقولون هذا تغيير جوهري سيبقى أثره معاكم للأبد
وسيكون فارق في مستقبل السعودية
والله سؤال جميل بصراحة
وأنا راح أحاول أركز على شيء أعتقد أنه هو زي ما أنت ذكرت غير ملموس
اليوم إذا نظرت على الشباب
وفرق العمل اللي قاعدة تشتغل في تنفيذ الرؤية
وتشوف كمية الالتزام، وكمية الشغف
الانتماء للرؤية
أنا بصراحة أحكي لك إياها
لي لفوق الثلاثين سنة في هذا المجال، ما شفته
جيل مختلف، وجيل يبغى يتعلم
حتى لما أتكلم معهم يقول لك أنا أبغى أسوي لأنها تخدم بلدي
هذا الشغف، والالتزام، وحب التعلم
وأنه يعرف كيف تُسوَّى الأمور بطريقة، والالتزام بالتوقيت
يعني هذه زمان احنا كنا، حتى أنا في المدرسة زمان
تعرف كلياتنا ما كان...
كان إهمال في التوقيت بالنسبة لي
الآن هذا لا، خلينا نسوي هذا لأنه كذا
أعتقد أكثر شيء هذا الالتزام من الشباب
اللي يشتغل لك أربعة عشر، وثمانية عشر ساعة
والله، يعني أنا ما كنت أتخيل هذا الموضوع
احنا زمان كانوا العملة يتطلعوا فينا
يا أخي أنتم مساكين الاستشاريين
تشتغلوا إثنا عشر، وثلاثة عشر فعلًا
هذا معروف عنكم أنه بيئة العمل عندكم قاتلة
يا ابن الحلال الآن احنا صرنا نقول للشباب في الجهات الحكومية
ريحونا
الله يعينكم، أنتم تشتغلوا صرنا احنا نروح، وهم لسَّه شغالين
هذا مكسب لا يُقاس
هذا الجيل اللي راح يكمل في الرؤية بعد الـ 2030
الخبرات اللي قاعدة تُكتسب
الالتزام جزء، يعني هم يمتلكوا رؤية
ما هو أن والله واحد أقول له نفِّذ...
أعتقد هذا أكبر مكسب
وأنا أقول لك أني كشركة «بي دبليو سي» بالعكس
أنا قلت لك أنه احنا 56%
احنا قاعدين نقول 60 و70%
أبغى هذه الشباب تكمل المشوار
سواءً في «بي دبليو سي» أو في الجهات الحكومية
وإن شاء الله، يا رب نوصل لمرحلة
اللي يكون الطلب خلينا نحكي، متوفر بس ما يكون زيادة
متوفر لكل الجهات اللي...
ما نحتاج نحط قوانين علشان نرفع نسبة المواطن في...
أنا بقول لك ما في داعي اليوم
طبعًا لازم تكون موجودة هي
بس أنا بالنسبة لي ما هي هذه المعيار اللي أمشي عليه
فأعتقد هذا أكبر مكسب للبلد من الرؤية
ويبني فريق بهذا المستوى، وهذا الالتزام
هذول، بإذن الله، اللي راح يكملوا الطريق
بإذن الله تعالى، شكرًا لك، أبو بدر
سعداء أنك لبِّيت الدعوة، وبالتوفيق في نقل المعرفة
وتوطينها، وتمكين هذا التحول
الله يعطيك العافية، وتشرَّفنا، وشكرًا لاستضافتي
الله يحييك
تشرّفنا فيك
بالعكس شكرًا لك، الله يسلمك
شكرًا لكم
وشكرًا لفهدة القصير في إعداد وإنتاج هذه الحلقة
فؤاد الهتلان في الإخراج الإبداعي
ياسر آل غانم في إدارة التصوير
وفي الإضاءة إسماعيل شوقي
في تسجيل الصوت عبد الرزاق المزِّي
وفي التحرير أنس الخليل
وفي الهندسة الصوتية عبد العزيز المزِّي
وفي إدارة الإنتاج عبد المجيد عمر
وفي الإشراف على الإنتاج رزان دهيثم
هذا بودكاست سُقراط
أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع